what is up guys fire here from awesome
toots dot-com and before we proceed to
create our game let us take a short
preview what is the game that you are
going to create so if I hit the play
button here we have a simple main menu
with some animations and a play button
nothing too fancy but hey you know me I
need to add some menus in the game and
show how you can navigate from one menu
to another man you because well people
are always confused about that so here
we can only click on the play button it
will take us right away in the gameplay
when we jump we hear some sounds so I am
gonna turn on or turn off my volume a
little bit you see some obstacles that
we have here and we need to avoid those
obstacles such as the ninja or the
squirrel that you just saw we can kill
all of these enemies while we are in the
air so while we are in the air we are
able to kill all the enemies but if we
are standing like this right here they
can kill us as you just saw when we die
we preview here the high score or the
height that we reached we can click
again to print play our game again or we
can well click on the main menu to go
back to the main menu so nothing too
fancy but hey we will see a lot of cool
features such as this right here for
example the camera is not moving at all
if I select the main camera you will see
that the position of the main camera is
at y equals 0 so we're not moving the
main camera at all we are moving the
actual backgrounds and what not and
moving the enemies and all of those cool
stuff we are gonna see so uh let's get
into it and create this cool game I'm
gonna go in another unity editor that I
have created and we are gonna import the
assets this is by the way a to the
project so when you create a new project
you're gonna select that 2d checkbox or
radio button not the 3d one name your
project and store it wherever you want
so first things first here are the
assets by the way these assets you can
download them link is in the description
below see
see something like wanna use the assets
for this tutorial and the complete
project you can get it on the link below
so click on the link and it will take
you where you can download these assets
so simply select all of these folders so
we have buttons and/or backgrounds and
buttons enemies and obstacles player and
the sounds so I'm gonna select all of
these folders and simply drag and drop
and right here in my unity editor and it
is gonna start importing all of those
assets besides from importing the assets
we are gonna create a main menu or the
main menu you just saw in the preview in
this video also so I'm gonna right click
here and create a new folder so again
it's right-clicking here in the project
tab so right click create a new folder
this is gonna be our scenes so not seen
but since it's plural not singular and
I'm gonna save this scene by holding
command and pressing s and it's gonna
open it here to save it of course or you
can go under file save scenes and bam
here you are I'm gonna select the scenes
folder and this is gonna be our main
menu so main menu and I'm gonna hit
enter now what do we need for our main
menu well of course we need a canvas and
we need the background image so I'm
gonna right click in the hierarchy tab
right here and by the way if you want to
rearrange how your unity editor looks
like you can simply drag and drop all of
these tabs you can put him here you can
I don't know put him right here you can
make them float like this if you like it
like that I don't know which techniques
you are using to you well create your
games but this is how you can do it and
you can save the layout for well later
reuse by going on the top right corner
right here you have the layout drop-down
list and then you can click on the save
layout and then simply name it here and
click Save and voila you're good to go
and I have saved mine as my layout and
if I click it again BAM this is what I
have let me just go here click on the
resolution and by the way I'm glad that
this has
because I see a lot of people have
troubles with this so I'm gonna use the
resolution 480 by 800 for this tutorial
now if you don't have it here if I
assume and you need to go under game tab
so game tab is right here if you don't
have it it's under window and then you
can click on game right here and any tab
that you see here animation animator
console here are key inspector they are
all under window and here they are
so scene tab game tab inspector here are
key project animation blah blah blah so
this is where you open these tabs now
regarding to the game tab right below it
you have a drop down list where you can
select resolutions mine is as I already
said 480 by 800 if you don't have it you
see this little plus circle right here
at the bottom you can click on that plus
circle and it's gonna open this pop-up
window the label here is the actual name
for your resolution so it can be full HD
for example here you have fixed
resolution or aspect ratio aspect ratios
like sixteen by nine sixteen by ten but
the fixed resolution is where you can
write 480 by 800 and when you click OK
BAM here it is full HD 480 800 these in
parentheses is the actual resolution and
the first thing here is the name I named
this on 480 by 800 as you can see here
in parenthesis that's the resolution I'm
gonna click it back again to my 480 by
800 and I'm gonna delete this full HD by
right clicking on it and clicking delete
and BAM this is how we do so this is how
we create these resolutions in game tab
moving forward in the hierarchy I'm
gonna right-click go under UI and create
an image now before I proceed to do
anything I'm gonna select the canvas
rename it to you I canvassed for the
render mode we have screen space overlay
screen space camera and world space I'm
gonna select screen screen space camera
and attach the main camera which is
going to
take this canvas obey the cameras you
can see this whole thing right here this
big thing this big rectangle is the
canvas but notice now when I drag the
main camera here for the render camera
BAM the canvas is right here where the
camera is if you want to know a little
bit more about these and what they are
the Unity Technologies has an official
tutorial explaining what is the render
mode for screen space overlay screen
space Cameron rules-based simply type
unity canvas render mode or canvas
tutorial or something like that and you
will find that video and I also talked
about this in my courses you can check
those courses out below is the link to
all of my courses so I'm gonna select
screen screen space camera as I already
said for that UI scale mode I'm not
gonna select scale bit pixel size or
constant pixel size I'm gonna select
scale with screen size and I'm gonna set
the resolution to be 480 by 800 the one
that we are using and here screen match
mode it's gonna be 0.5 so that the
canvas and his UI children will match
the width and the height equally now
taking this image I'm gonna put it in
the middle of the screen this is what we
see here and if we go back into the
project and the backgrounds and buttons
right here we have the background so if
I select the UI image and I'm gonna drag
and drop the background right here and
Bend here it is this is our background
now of course here I'm gonna see
background image I'm gonna click on
native size so set native size this is
when we select the image and in the
inspector panel in the camera or here in
the image we have a property and we have
a button called
set native size if I click on it BAM
here it is this is the native size of
our background so you can see here the
background now is covering the whole
screen we are also gonna duplicate this
background and it's gonna be the title
so here I'm gonna name it title image
subtitle I am
gr image and I'm gonna search here in
backgrounds and images for title here it
is this is title and I'm gonna put it
right here where the source image is and
been here it is this is our image now
again in regards to dragging and
dropping these images you can simply
drag and drop it like well like I did or
you can click on the little circle here
where it says source image and then you
can search for the image right here and
simply type for example title here it is
and bam here you are and title is spelt
UT what did I do here let me just go
here and it's title like this is pelo -
t yeah I don't care I'm gonna spell it
like that and in regards to the width
and the height of the title image is
gonna be 430 so 430 for the width and
for the height 390 and position Y I'm
gonna say it - 5 - this is where we want
it so this is what we currently have for
that image now when you select it here
you have a rect transform and you have
position x position Y position Z width
and the height this is where I set the
width for 30 and the height 390 let me
just fix the scale to 1 if for some
reason it's at point 9 9 so I just fix
it for well to be at 1 what we also need
is a button background which is also
gonna be well an image I'm gonna
duplicate this title image and there's
gonna be BT and BG - so I'm gonna name
it and it's this blue shield so simply
select the button BG drag and drop the
blue shield right here it says source
image and BAM here it is now the width
of this is going to be at 372 the height
is gonna be 206 and the position Y for
it is gonna be at 31 why like that well
now because we have a button and in
order to create a button we simply need
to right click you eye and we have a
button and bam here it is this is our
button now we are not gonna use this
default one we are gonna edit it so this
is gonna be our play BT and this I'm
gonna name
if you click on the drop down list for
the button you will see it has a text by
default you see this button that is
written that's because of the text if I
deactivated you see we don't have the
text anymore so I'm gonna delete it we
don't need it and select the play button
and select the play texture drag and
drop it here under source image UI
sprite and bam here we are the width of
this is going to be 181 and the height
is gonna be 75 and position x4 it's
gonna be zero position Y is gonna be 23
so this is our main menu now you saw in
the preview that this circle was well
circling around it had an animation this
jungle was also stretching and going
back stretching and going back so these
are the animations that we are gonna
create but we're gonna start with that
in the next video and now that we have
finished our main menu let us animate
the title and this circle which is well
the background for our button just as we
saw in the preview video before we do
that I'm gonna right click here in the
project tab and create a new folder
where we are gonna store our animation
so here I'm gonna well name the folder
animations inside of it we're gonna
create another folder it is gonna be our
title animation and another folder so
right click create folder this is gonna
be our circles of circle animation or
however you want to name it but this
circle is the circle background for the
button this is really important with
this I mean organization don't you throw
things away in your project like put the
animations anywhere I mean you can do
that but it will get your project really
messy so it's a good idea to create
folders such as these so animations and
here are gonna store that animations and
title animation this is where we are
gonna create an animation for our title
so in order to create that animation you
need to select the title image here it
is and go in the animation tab which is
this one right here I've talked about
these tabs in the previous video
if you don't have a tab right here
called animation you can go under window
and here it is BAM now let me
demonstrate that so if I close the tab I
don't have it anymore I need it so I'm
gonna go under window click animation
and bam here it is in most cases is
gonna be floating like this sometimes it
is docked like this for example but if
it's floating and you wanna put it
somewhere else simply take it like this
and drag and drop it wherever you want
it this is my set up by the way for
unity editor you don't need to do it
like this you can have your own set up
experiment with it and then simply save
it here under well any layout name that
you want so now that we have the title
image selected which is really important
so select that title image that is
really important when you select it go
into animation tab and now you can click
on create animation so let me just
select the title image again to begin
animating title image create an animator
and animation clip so we're gonna click
on create which is gonna create this
pop-up window or open it and here in the
title animation folder so you see here
I'm in assets animations title animation
this is where I'm gonna save these
animations I'm gonna call this one
title animation and I'm gonna hit enter
and bam here we are so now we can start
animating our title image if we go here
into the project and title animation
folder you see here we have title
animation this is the animation clip
itself title image this is the
controller so if I select title image
you will see now the animator component
is attached on it this title image as
you can see here is the controller so
animator controller for this animator
now what we need to do we need to go
into the animation select the title
image again you see this little red
button right here or I'm pointing with
my mouse so here it is under the
animation tab you have these play rewind
go to previous keyframe go to next
keyframe and here you have this
red image enable/disable keyframe
recording mode if you played with any
video editing software you know this or
this red key icon is from familiar to
you so when we press on it it will start
recording everything so what we need to
do here well first things first we are
gonna change the width and the height of
our title so I'm gonna go under frame 15
and by the way you see these samples
here at 60 that means we have 60 frames
in this animation but here you see this
tab where it says 0 here I can type 15
which means it will take me to frame 15
you see now this line here indicating
where we are in that animation this
white line is now on frame 15 what
happens on frame 15 well I'm gonna
change the width to 230 and I'm gonna
change the height to 350 for the title
that's 250 but 350 now after that I'm
gonna go on frame 30 so here I'm gonna
instead of 15 type 30 hit enter which is
gonna take me to frame 30 and on frame
30 I'm gonna set the width to 190 and
the height is gonna be at 350 I'm not
gonna touch it now I'm gonna go back to
frame 45 or not go back but actually go
to frame 45 hit enter here I'm gonna set
the width to be 290 the height is gonna
be 360 and lastly we're gonna go on
frame 60 so here instead of 45 type 60
hit enter here I'm gonna say the width
is gonna be 440 and the height is gonna
be 400 so now I can click again on the
recording button it will stop recording
everything and well voila we are good
with the animation so we can well
preview the animation in or did you
preview it I can go back here click on
display button you see the
is the jungle run animation we can also
run the game so if we hit the play
button now this is the jungle run
animation now you see I don't want it to
be this fast how can we change this well
in order to change that we can go in the
animator tab you see here now we have
the animator tab again if you don't see
it under window you have animation and
you'll also have animator tab the
animator tab displays these animation
clips so you see title animation is
right here we can double click on this
and you see here it has the loop time
check which means it will loop the
animation itself if this is not checked
it would not loop that animation now
what we need to do here is click on the
title animation and you see here the
speed of the animation is 1 which means
100 normal speed of animation I am gonna
click point 5 which is gonna play that
animation two times slower then its own
actual speed so if I hit the play button
now you see the Jungle Run animation
plays a little bit slower so actually
please have the speed it did before so
in order to do that again you need to go
in to the animator tab select the title
animation if you select something else
sometimes if you select something else
it will not display anything here but
make sure that you select the game
object you want to edit and you will see
all of its animations right here so I'm
gonna click on title animation and in
the inspector panel right here you have
the speed property setting it at point
five will make it go half the speed of
its original speed so half of its
original speed so again if I hit the Run
button BAM this is what we have right
here
let us now animate the circle and in
order to do that select the button BG
again click here create and we're not
gonna see that in the title animation
we're gonna save it in the circle
animation right here so I'm gonna name
it circle animation like this and hit
say
and bam here we are now we are going to
do a similar thing and that is we're
gonna click on the recording button go
on frame 30 and we're gonna edit here
the Z rotation so the rotation here
we're gonna set it at negative 360 and
we're gonna go on frame 60 now so frame
6-0 and we're gonna set this at negative
720 so if I stop recording now and hit
the play button you see our well circle
is rotating and if I hit the play button
again BAM you see the circle is rotating
jungle run is also stretching and going
wire is stretching and going wider and
whatnot now in regards to the circle you
see it's rotating then stopping the
rotating and stopping this is because of
the animation now we can fix this with
some lines of code I didn't like this
but you can create a script attach it
and animate it or actually simply make
it rotate with code I'm not going to
show you how to do that you can search
that on the internet but I'm just
pointing out that air that there are
multiple ways to solve a certain problem
in well programming and that's why when
people ask me why did you do it like
this what did you do this like this why
did you do that that was my own
preference I thought that that was the
best way to solve that in that
particular moment which does not mean
it's the best code to solve something
you can always always always optimize
your code you can always add some new
things to make things work better son
and so forth so if you see me do
something that is my own logic I use
animations here too well create these
effects I did not use code even though
all of this right here did you see the
stretching of the title rotating of the
circle all of this is doable through
code but this is the more simpler way
and that's why I am showing you how to
do it like that so now let's go into our
game play scene so what we need to do is
first click on file and then you
scene shortcut for that is command and
on Mac ctrl + n on Windows
so if I click new scenes gonna take me
right here and I'm gonna hold command
press s to save it so assets scenes this
one is gonna be named game play the
first thing that I wanna do is set up
our game play scene yes again we're
gonna set up things still we're not
gonna code so I deal with it I don't
care anyways I'm gonna right click here
in the hierarchy panel go under UI and
create an image this is gonna be our
background it comes with a canvas
right-of-way so I'm gonna rename it to
UI canvas change it from screen space
overlay to screen space camera and
attach the main camera right here take
the image and I'm gonna set it at 0 0 0
but before or after I do that we are
gonna set the UI scale mode to scale
with screen size 480 by 800 and we are
gonna match width and height equally now
what we need to do is we need to add a
background to our image and that is
gonna be under backgrounds and buttons
the sky image so let me take it right
here rename it to background instead of
image drag and drop the sky image right
here where the sprite is and click on
set native size now you see the image is
not how we wanted it to be because of
that I'm simply gonna set it at 480 by
800 for the width and the height and
voila here is our image I'm also gonna
change the color now we have this purple
white color I don't want that so for the
color in the image property we have the
color hex color right here is gonna be
at 7 6 F 9 so 7 6 F 9 f FF this is the
color that we want so let me just go
here in the game yeah this is exactly
the color that we want to have now what
we are gonna do is create another image
by duplicating the background image is
simply duplicated and these are going to
be our back
trees like this and for that we need to
search well for our tree one image so
I'm simply gonna put it right here
instead of the sky now this is not how
we want them to be so I'm gonna change
the way to 560 and the height to 450 and
the position I'm gonna say here for the
Y negative 212 and voila
these are our back ground background
trees of course since we have duplicated
this background we have changed the
color so I'm gonna put the color back to
white or the normal color so now they
are green as any normal trees while our
we are also gonna take other trees which
are our front trees so and you just take
them right here and place them well
something like this now these are gonna
be our front trees because they are in
front of these trees and this one let me
just name them front tree one I'm gonna
set it here so let me say point five for
the X point six for the Y that is the
scale of it and notice please notice
this is not a UI element so this is a
simple game object I have simply dragged
and dropped these trees right here in
the scene folder or actually in the
scene view so I did not create a UI
element for them as you can see we have
the background then we have the trees if
I turn of the canvas we are left with
the front trees so don't be confused
they are not a UI element they are a
simple game object now here I'm gonna
set it at negative three point let's say
three and for the Y I'm gonna say
negative three point five so this is
what I'm gonna place this tree and for
our other trees I'm simply gonna
duplicate these and this is gonna be our
front tree let me duplicate it again so
this is gonna be our front tree - now
this one is gonna be position it at
three so negative three or actually
positive three and for the Y I'm gonna
say three point nine so these are the
trees that are gonna be in our game
gives that depth effect for our game now
the next thing that we need to do is we
need to add our bounce and for that we
have the bounce right here so they are
and we just find them right here at
shield side boundaries here they are so
these are the bounds that we want to add
in our game now we are gonna have we're
gonna duplicate these but before we do
that I'm gonna change their scale to be
0.76 on the X I'm not gonna touch
anything on the Y and I'm gonna set 0 0
0 4 well the X and the y position so
this is our level this right here that
you see is our level what we need to do
now is we need to add two box colliders
to them why - well because I don't want
to I'm not gonna slice these if I open
these as you can see these are two
separate boundaries so one is here and
another is here I'm not gonna use the
slice machine or the slice sprite editor
right here to slice it like this so one
is here and another is here I don't want
to do that instead I'm gonna use them as
they are but I need to add two box
colliders on them because we don't want
or we want to prevent collision from our
player going outside of these so if I
take the side boundaries we are gonna
add one box Collider and we are gonna
add another box Collider really really
really important to know when you are
working in a 2d projects you're working
with a 2-d game when you filter for a
box Collider so you have a box Collider
here and you have a box Collider 2d box
Collider is for 3d game objects so be
very very careful about that
box Collider 2d is for 2d so you need to
be careful about it because if you add a
box Collider this one the 3d one your
code will not work because we are
working with 2d so what we're gonna do
with the first box Collider
well offset is gonna be at 4 actually
here offset it's gonna be four point
twenty nine we're not gonna touch offset
Y size X is gonna be one point
six one and the size Y is gonna be 1024
and if I take all of these game objects
and deactivate and we will see what I'm
talking about so I'm gonna take the
other box Collider which is this one
right here and for this one we are gonna
say well the offset is gonna be at
negative so this one's gonna be negative
four point twenty nine offset Y we're
not gonna touch it size is gonna be one
point six one so one point six one we're
not gonna touch well the other size for
the Y as you can see here we have two
Box colliders let me just take this
right here and position it here so he
can see it
one box Collider is here and if I move
it let me just move on of these okay I'm
moving this one on the left side you see
I'm moving it let me just remember or
memorize the value so I'm moving it this
is one of the Box cool as you see it the
green thing right here this is for the
left one and this one right here the
other one this right here is for the
well right one so we have two of these
that are gonna represent boundaries on
our to let's say call these pipes I'm
gonna call them pipes and I don't care
if they are if they are not actually
pipes I'm gonna call them pipes don't
you come with me okay technically there
are not pipes there are this I don't
care okay
so we need three more of these so on and
this one is gonna be positioned at 10
for the y2 this was gonna be positioned
at 24 do I and 3 and this one is gonna
be positioned at 34 well on the Y so
this is what we have these are the
boundaries and since I am a control
freak or organization freak I'm gonna
right click here create an empty game
object and I'm gonna name this one play
your bounds like this position this at 0
0 0 now when I say position this empty
game object at 0 0 0 that does not mean
anything I just like them to be
positioned like that I don't want this
to be at 200 here and 351 no I want them
at 0 0 0 select all four of our bounds
so we have side boundaries 1 2 & 3
drag and drop them under the player
bombs which
is our parent game object and voila this
is what we have this is our official
level and we are done with editing it
the next thing that we need to do is
actually make these bounds move you see
we need to make them move like this in
order to simulate an infinite background
effect and we will start doing that from
the next video so let's get into some
coding inside of the project tab I'm
gonna right click and create a new
folder which I'm gonna call well you can
assume scripts I mean duh and here I'm
gonna right-click and create a new
folder and this is gonna be our BG
scripts because here we're gonna store
the background scripts or actually the
ones that are gonna move these pipes or
these obstacles or bounds or however you
want to call them so here I'm gonna
right-click create here BG mover so BG
mover like this and we need to attach it
on all of our side boundaries so I'm
gonna select all of them by well
selecting one holding shift then
selecting well all of these and right
here under add component I am gonna
filter for the BG mover and hit enter
and this is well the way to add this
script to all four of our bounce now I'm
gonna double click the script and open
it here in mono behavior actually
monodevelop I'm gonna tag the class here
at the bottom hold enter just to give a
little bit of space as always which we
are used for me to do so we need a
couple of variables as always when we
start a script the first one is gonna be
a public float which is gonna be the
move speed I'm gonna set it at 3 by
default let's say 5 by default this is
the default value I set it to be public
which means it will be visible here in
the inspector panel bad here it is so we
have the BG mover script we have the
move speed value right here default 1 is
5 as we just saw we also need to get a
reference to private game object and
there's gonna be an array and
are gonna be our side bounce not sounds
but side bounce what is this well we're
gonna get all four of these boundaries
from the scene because while we need to
calculate where we need to reposition
each bound so we will see that in a
second we also need a private float so
float there's gonna be our camera Y this
is the Y position of the camera we also
need a private float and this is gonna
be our bound height this is the height
of our bounce and this is all what we
need for now inside of the awake
function so I'm gonna change start to
awake and I always always always get
this question why did you change a week
or start to wake why are you using a way
you can not start you can use either
awake or start but I talked about this
all the time and all the time I get
questions about this so we have awake
we have void start like this and we have
void on enable all three of these all
three of these functions are used for
initialization now the difference is in
the order of execution the first
function is gonna be called when you
start the game is awake function the
next one will be on enable and the third
one will be start now usually you are
gonna use awake and start and awake is
called before start that's why I like to
use awake it's my own preference you can
use start as well and it will work the
same way so inside of the awake we need
to get the reference to all of these
bounds but we need to get them using
their tack and in order to do that we
need to go back here in the scene editor
or unity editor when you select any of
these game objects you will see here in
the inspector panel below the name of
the game object you have these tags it's
a drop-down list so you can click on the
drop-down list and you can go here add
tag so click on that and then here you
can create your own custom tag by
clicking on this plus button right
so if I click on the custom plus button
I can create my own tag which I'm gonna
call side bounce like this or side bound
however you want it and I'm gonna click
Save
so it's side bound they are put together
this is one word no space between side
and bound this is important because now
we need to tag so select all of these
side boundaries and from the tag now you
can select that side bound that we have
created as our own custom tag so here it
is when you select it notice now every
single one of eisah our side boundaries
will have that side bound tag so at all
four of them now why did I say this is
important so it's important because now
we can go here in our awake and we can
say side bounds is equal to game object
find game objects so here we have plural
not singular so s it's object with s we
can remove that and we can only find one
game object with the tag but since we
need an array meaning all game objects
in the scene which carry the tag that we
specify right here so the tag is side
bound now what is important here this
side bound this tag name right here
needs to be exactly as the name a right
here so we see its side bound no space
between side and bound if we do
something like this here type space
between them we will not find those game
objects and we will have a problem so
it's me it needs to be the same same
signature same capitalization everything
needs to be the same we also are going
to get the camera why so camera why is
going to be equal to camera that main
that transformer actually die game
object that transform that position that
Y so this is gonna give us the Y
position of the camera and what we also
need to calculate is the bound height
which we calculate by using the box
Collider so we need to get the box
now notice both box colliders have the
same size on the y-axis so it does not
matter which box Collider we get so
simply here we need to type get
component box Collider 2d and we need to
say bounce that size that why this is
gonna give us the height so how high how
large when I say how high don't think
about smoking weed or something like
that it's the height so how high is the
bound game object this is important
because well we need to recalculate its
position before we do that so before we
recalculate the position we are gonna
move it so we're gonna see here void
move this is a function that we have
just created which you're gonna call in
the update right here to move our game
objects our bounce and we're gonna do it
simply by using vector three temporary
variable is equal to transform that
position so the current position of the
game object temp that Y is gonna be
minus equal to move speed multiplied by
time dot delta time and below we simply
to say transform position is equal to u
temp what are we doing here because some
students do not understand this if I
take my highlight tool we have created a
temporary variable so this is a variable
temp to temporary store the value so to
store the current value of our own
positions of POS so our current position
is stored in the temporary variable so
now we are using the vy y value of the
temporary variable subtracting from it
the move speed so move speed speed like
this multiplied with the time delta time
now timed out delta time is a very small
number between each frame so if we have
60 frames in a second that is a very
very small number and it's used in
calculations like this and simply then
we use our current position so POS and
we assign it
new position which is our temp that's
the new position
so simply reassigning it back so
currently here here we are storing it so
this is our current position we have
edited our current position and we
reassignment back so that we have a new
value of the position so think of it
like this I have ten dollars and I give
you that ten dollars so I give it to you
and I tell you okay these are my ten
dollars stored them for me so temporary
hold them for me but also go and buy me
some gums and that gum cost one dollar
for example so one dollar is the gum so
now from ten you have nine so that means
you have nine now you bought me the gun
and I tell you okay give me back my
money so now you give me back the
current value or the edited value which
is now nine and not 10 anymore so it's
not ten now it's nine so we are done
with the movement so here we have well
calculated a new position we are calling
that in the update function we can go
back here and we can well simply hit
that play button to see that they are
actually moving down you see they are
moving down and eventually they will ran
out and bam this is the trouble that we
have or the problem well that we have
now it's not that bad idea since we have
these box colliders on these game
objects we can select all of these we
can add a rigidbody 2d because if I just
move it up let me just move the
component up and why did I add a
rigidbody to all of these game objects
well the reason for it is because we
have box colliders on them and when you
want to move game objects with colliders
it is a good idea to add a rigidbody on
them but before I proceed I will show
you one problem that we have so our game
objects are simply gonna fall down you
see they just fell down now you might
think this is okay because we have the
script but if I deactivate the script
that is moving them even if I remove it
they're gonna fall down you see they're
falling down the reason for it is
because the rigidbody is
applying gravity to our game objects so
what we need to do is we need to go here
and set them to be kinematic so here
from the drop-down list body type is not
dynamic anymore its kinematic so I'm
gonna put them here as kinematic and if
I hit the play button so now they are
going down but because of the script if
I deactivate the scripts of BG mover is
deactivated they are not moving down as
you can see they are not affected by
gravity anymore so they are not affected
by gravity if I change that dynamic BAM
they are falling down and this is what I
mean so let me turn it back the script
on again and put the body to kinematic
all four of these bodies so it's a good
idea when you have a Collider on a game
object and you're moving it that you
that you actually put a rigidbody on it
if you don't want gravity then simply
put it to be kinematic but leave the
rigidbody on that game object so what is
the problem that we have now well the
problem is that we are moving these
backgrounds and eventually they are
gonna well go away and we are not gonna
have them anymore so BAM as you can see
right here now also one thing that we
are gonna do in regards to our side
bounds is that we are gonna take these
trees and let me just take them position
negative two because I want these trees
to be in front of our well obstacles
here or side bounce you see the trees
are now in front if I put them back at Z
so Z position isn't negative two if I
put it back at zero you see in the front
line we see I'm not sure if you're
actually seeing this I'm gonna zoom it
back so here notice all of the trees are
behind these bounds if I put the front
trees at negative two for the Z they're
now in front of the boundaries because I
wanna create that depth effect so now
I'm moving back to our script what we
need to do is we need to reposition them
so here I'm gonna say void reposition
and we need to call this function right
below the move function so right below
it here call reposition
in a side of the reposition we are going
to test if our bounds are below the
cameras Y position so here we're gonna
test if the transform position which is
the current position of our bounce that
Y is actually less than the camera Y and
for the camera Y we also are gonna do
the following here so we got the camera
Y I'm also gonna subtract 15 so I'm
gonna see here minus 15 just so that I
can give a little bit of space before we
actually reposition the background so if
our current position Y is less than the
cameras Y position of course we have
subtracted 15 from it right here so if
our position is less we need to
reposition our background how we're
gonna do that
what we need to calculate the highest Y
of the backgrounds Y the highest well
notice here in the scene you see the
first bounce this one that are here you
see I'm deactivating and these first are
at position zero for the Y the next one
are at 10 the third one are at 20 and
the fourth one are at 30 so what we need
to do when this side bound right here so
when it goes like this and goes below
the camera somewhere around here we need
to reposition it back in front right
here so that it can again go down like
this and then be positioned back and
again and again so this effect is what
we are gonna achieve so let me position
this at 0 0 for X and the y to put it
back where it was
and in order to do that we're gonna say
here float highest bounce Y so this is
the highest bounce y is gonna be equal
to side bounce element that's it index 0
that transform that position that Y how
can I be sure that the first element in
this array is the one that has the
highest Y position well I'm not because
when we use this game objects or game
object find game objects with
it's gonna get all of these game objects
that have this tag and put it in this
array now the order by which this
function gets these game objects is
always different it does not get them
like this so side bounds will be element
0 side boundaries one will be element
one side boundaries two will be element
two you know it can be that side
boundaries two is element zero or at
element zero index zero that is side
boundaries three can be an element or
index one side boundaries can be at
index two and side by boundaries one can
be at index 3 now my point is that it
will not get them in this order so that
the last or first element will always be
the one with the highest Y position
instead we need to compare the value so
here are gonna say if or actually we are
gonna say for INT i which is equal to 1
y1 well because here we used 0 0 index
we don't need to test element that's an
index 0 instead we are going to test
other elements so for y or int i that's
equal to 1 I is less than side bounds
that length I plus plus so we're gonna
filter through the array and we're gonna
test if the highest bounce Y which we
assigned to be equal to Y well this
right here if it's less than side bounce
element that's an index Y dot transform
that position that Y that means that
this element here at index I in the
array has the higher value for the y
axis which means that we're gonna say
our highest bounds Y is equal to this
right here like this so what we are
doing here let me just go here and well
demonstrate this with a highlight tool
let's imagine that element at index 0
has a value of let's say 5 for Y so
here's Y is equal to 5 we assign that to
the highest bounce now that does not
guarantee the
this right here the element that said
index zero actually has the highest
value for his y-axis that's the reason
why we are testing so we are looping
through the array here and testing if
the current value of our highest bounds
Y is less than Y axis or Y value from
the element that's it index Y if that is
true so let's say this I currently has
value one that's element at index one
and that element and index one has a
y-value of seven so the Y value here is
seven which means this value here the
first one is actually less than seven so
we're testing if it's less and that is
true that means we need to reassign this
seven to this value because it is the
higher value so this is what we are
doing here so now that we have the
highest Y value for our bounds what we
need to do is simply we need to say here
vector three temporary position is equal
to the transform that position and we
need to say the Y value of our current
bound is going to be equal to highest
bounce so highest bounce y plus the
bound height and that is that and here
we simply need to say transform that
position is equal to temp Y the bound
height well if I go here let's say the
highest value is 30 and we want to
reposition this one so we want to
reposition this one here now if I say
that the highest Y value is 30 and I
want to position it above the one and if
I put it here at 30 notice it's at the
same spot so it's exactly here you see
we have this one it's right below it let
me just go here come on reposition back
so it's at 30 so it's at the same you
see they are at the same position here
we don't want it we want this one to be
above that one right here and we know
that all four of the
bounds have the same height so we can
use that so we can say okay I want this
to be at position 30 but also I want to
add to it its height and its height is
equal to 10 so that means plus 10 that
mean is 40 which means BAM it will
position you see it will position it
above the down ones of the previous one
actually it will reposition it back so
we have it right here so we have
calculated we're calling this let me
just save the script it's really
important what did I do here okay so I
just duplicated this code so sorry for
that anyways it's really important that
you save your scripts every time you
type some coming out command s or ctrl s
on Windows to save the changes in your
script so we are calling these functions
here and let's see that magic happens so
if I go here hit the play button in the
scene notice now when this one you see
its repositioning about did you see that
it is repositioning back these
backgrounds and notice here how we have
that in our game so this is how we have
it in our game you see that little gap
that we had yeah we have this gap right
here so we can fix that gap by doing
something like this so we can say bound
height let's say minus one just to well
subtract one from our bound height so
that we can actually fill out that gap
so if I go back here let's see if we
have that gap again between these no so
yeah this is the effect that we want we
don't have the gap between our bounds
that we had well a moment ago just by
subtracting one to fill out that gap and
notice they are repositioning this whole
time it's calculating where is the
highest y-value all the time and it is
putting these back up and up and up and
up so we have this infinite background
effect and if you take a look at here
you have an assumption so you have a
feeling like the camera is moving but
actually no the bounds are moving down
and you think the camera is moving
upwards so this is some new features
that we have learned so far because most
of the time in infinite runner games
that
did or tutorials that I did for infinite
runner effect games I move the camera
but now I'm moving the game objects
themselves so you see what I was talking
about you see this one it's gonna be
repositioned on the top BAM it's on the
top and again and again they are
stacking upon one another so this is
what we are doing here calculating the
highest Y and repositioning it back
using the highest Y plus the bound
height minus 1 to fill out that gap and
now that we have our obstacles moving
let us add our player in the game now
before we do that inside of this assets
folder we have the player enemies and
obstacles and backgrounds and boxes we
can create a new folder here so I'm
gonna name this one two sprites and
select player enemies and obstacles
backgrounds and buttons and put all of
this inside of that sprites folder just
so that we group our sprites right here
in one place so if we go here inside of
our player folder first sprites then
player we have these player animations
here so we have the run animation
jumping animation and fall down which is
his dead animation what we need to do is
create a new animation for the player
before that in the animations folder I'm
gonna right click and create a new
folder
this is gonna be player animations and
here is where we are gonna put the
player animations so sprites player
select the run animation this one right
here and well drag and drop all four of
these so one two three four and drag and
drop them right here in the scene view
and now when we do that BAM this pop-up
window pops up asking us to create an
animation because we added four or
selected four images and we're gonna
select animations folder player
animation and here I'm gonna call this
one run all right and hit enter to save
this gonna be our run write animation
for the player why run right well we'll
see that in a second first I'm gonna
rename this game object to player he is
too big for our game as we see
right here so we need to well resize him
select the player scale on the axis
point you on the Y point you on the Z
point to here I'm gonna say 2 for the x
axis and negative 1 on the y axis this
is where we are gonna put our players so
this right here and let me also take the
player and change his Z position let's
say Z is gonna be a negative 4 just so
that our player is visible on top of the
obstacle if I hit the run but now notice
what we have our player is running on
the obstacle before we proceed with the
animations because we need to well
prepare these animations for our player
we are gonna click here under add
component filter for box Collider 2d and
voila
here is our player so we have the Box
Collider here and I'm gonna resize it
because as you can see you see this
right here this is not how we want it so
I'm gonna set the size on the X at two
point ninety eight size on the Y let's
say five point nine and off set it on
the x axis by one point thirty-four so
this is what we have for our box
Collider voila let me just put the
player back here and to you for the X
and we need to add a rigidbody as I
already said for our player because we
will be moving him and he has a box
Collider and filter for rigidbody 2d we
need to make it to be kinematic because
if we leave it like this now BAM you see
the player fell down which is not what
we want so select the body type here
drop down list and click on kinematic
and we are done or good to go going back
into the assets folder in the project
right-click create a new folder for
prefabs and inside of the prefabs folder
go right here right click create folder
player prefabs not play fraps prefabs
like this and voila
here we are drag and drop the player
here because it's a good idea to create
prefabs out of game objects that you
because a prefab is a reusable game
object if I drag and drop the player
right here here we have another player
and all of the features or all of the
settings that we had for this player now
this prefab also has and when we change
something on our player this one right
here we can hit apply at the top right
corner so that that change also will
apply to the prefab before we proceed
with some scripting we need to go here
in animation select the player himself
and create a new animation we know that
when we want to create a new animation
if I select the tree we have this create
button and I click create and then we
can select where we want to save that
animation blah blah blah but when we
select the player now we don't have that
the reason for it is because the player
has his animations
he has his controller an animator
component attached on him so in order to
create a new animation right below the
red recording button we have this
drop-down list and we can click on it
and we can click here create new clip
this is gonna be our jump animation now
since we are on the right side right
here we are gonna jump from right to
left so here I'm gonna create a new clip
and I'm gonna call this one jump left
animation and save it as sets animations
player animations and click Save what we
need to do is put this animator tab
right here go into the sprites player
folder and we have these jump cycles so
we have four of them drag and drop them
and put him right here and here they are
let me just zoom in a little bit
zoom in a little bit more and voila here
they are now I don't want them to be
right here right next to each other
because like that notice here this is
the animation now that we have this is
our jump left you see the player is like
crazy and we do not want that so we are
gonna take these keyframes so take these
three keyframes and move them like this
and let's go on key on frame 15 so let
me just move these keyframes a little
bit more
frame 15 this one right here drag these
two or the first two keyframes so these
two drag them on frame 15 we're also
gonna go on frame 30 and you see where
this is going so here we have frame 30
this one right here let me just take two
keyframes and put this on frame 30 and
frame
well 45 put these two keyframes actually
we can move these a little bit something
like this so that I can put this on key
frame or these key frames something like
this so first two key frames you see
they're gonna be on frame 15 next you on
Kate on frame 30 then frame 45 so these
do you need to be on frame 45 and these
two are on frame 60 because our
animation looks a little bit better now
you see here our animation looks a
little bit better don't worry about the
animation being slow we will speed it up
in the animator panel so we will speed
it up so don't worry about that but the
important thing is that we have created
that animation now as you can see our
animation is not that good you see the
player is very small when we stop the
animation this is the players normal
size and whatnot so in order for us to
begin the scripting we need to fix these
animations because we are not gonna use
some code that's gonna put our player
from this position to this position
instead we're gonna use all animations
so we will animate the player running on
the right side then animate the player
running on the left side and animating
the player jumping from left to right
and vice versa from right to left so
what we also need to do is go in the run
animation run right I called it run
right for a reason because we need to
hit the preview or actually the
recording key we need to hit it change
the X like this change it to any value
so X position change it to any value and
now put it on to you and go on the last
frame this one right here and again put
it on
you are actually changing just so the
tween record when I say change we need
to record so that we record this
keyframe so we need to have these
keyframes as you can see now we have our
player sprite position but put it again
at - why - because this is the players
running a right animation as you can see
right here so we have him running on the
right side because we are also gonna
have him running on the left side and in
order to have him running on the left
side we need to select the player go in
the animator select the run right and
duplicate it not jump left duplicate the
run right animation so here it is and
now take the run right enemy should
rename it from run right zero to run
left and hit enter and bam save this
select the player again going to the
animation tab and now we have so we
should actually have another animation
no we don't so we need to improvise and
go back here delete this one and create
a new animation I thought this is gonna
work so create a new animation clip and
this is gonna be our run right because
or actually run left so run left and
again we need to drag and drop our
animation so go here we have running
animations these here and let me just go
here and see where they are let me
compare them with the running right so
yeah they go from well zero up to three
frames so this is okay and this one
right here run left does the same exact
thing so does the same the same exact
thing but what we need to do is the
following
hit the recording button so hit the
recording because now we need to well
run on the left side which means that
our player needs to be on negative - you
see right here and also negative zero
points you on his scale and we need to
go here on the last frame and just
change the position just so notice here
notice we don't have keyframes right
here but if I
change the position BAM you see we have
keyframes right away so put it at
negative two and also change the scale
just a little bit just so that we get
the keyframes and we are gonna set it at
point two why is that well now we have
the animation running the player from
well on the right side and also we have
the player running on the left side if I
hear the play button you see this is
what we have a right here now don't
worry about the animation being that
fast we can always always well turn it
down a little bit so if I go here inside
of that animation this one has 60 if I
set it to 12 and if I hit the play
button so yeah simply change the frames
you have here samples you see samples
are set on 60 between 60 frames in a
second and the player is running like
crazy see like a Rotorua but we don't
want that set the samples on 12 because
for the run right samples are also on 12
so the player runs like this let me just
go back to run left it's the same exact
thing now in regards to the jump left
animation what we need to do so we need
to animate our player jumping well from
right to left before we actually animate
our player jumping from right to left
let us select the first three keyframes
and put it back like this so the first
one will be at zero the second two will
be at 15 and the second three or the
third two keyframes will be at frame 30
the last key frames can be on frame
while 60 or the last frame right here
because this will make that animation
look a little bit better now what we
need to do is go on frame 30 and when
our player jumps we are gonna hit here
the record button set the position Y at
0 and set the position X at 0 so that
our player gets here and go on the last
frame set the Y position at negative 1
and the exposition
at negative 2 because now you see this
is that animation of our player jumping
now our player is very small you see
here when he jumps he gets very small we
don't want that so going here on frame 0
hit the recording button set the skill
at point 35 for the X and point 35 for
the Y so Y and X are gonna be 0.35 do
the same thing here for our well for the
last frame let me just put it like this
and like this so now I'm gonna set it
35:35 so simply change number at the
last frame so that you get the keyframes
and put them back so the skill is 0.35
skills EADS not important only x and y
so notice now when we jump this is what
we have here so player is jumping don't
worry about the animation being a little
bit slow we will fix that later on in
our code we can go here in the animator
and we have well jump left let me just
see where my animations are so we have
run right a run left here it is let me
just resize the window so that we can
see more clearly run right and run left
and we have jump left and we will have
jump right so if I take it here and put
it a 2.5 speed it will run two times two
and a half times faster you see as its
original speed but we can see that in
our game now this right here is a set up
for our player animation because this
way it is much easier we can simply use
the jump left animation the player
jumped from right to left and then from
here we can continue to play run left
animation which is this one right here
and when the player jumps from right to
left we can continue to play the run
right animation which is this one right
here this is much more easy or easier
than if we had to do all of this from
our code now to get this or to paint a
clear picture to see how easy this is
actually we need to start coding but we
are gonna do that from the next video
and fire
from awesome toots dot-com if you missed
something in regards to these animations
you can rewind the video to see how I
animated everything or download the
complete project link is in the
description below to see how I set
things to be animated and now that we
have our player animations
let us program the player while players
movement and jumping so if we go here in
the scripts folder right click create a
new folder layer scripts inside of this
folder right click and create a new C
sharp script let's call it player play a
planar and attach it on the player right
here hit apply so that this change
applies to the prefab what we need for
our player what we need to animate the
player we also need to be able to click
on the screen and make the player jump
so before we continue to program we need
to add a UI button right here in the
middle so if we take our canvas right
click and go under UI and create a
button BAM here it is this is our button
now we need to resize it so resize the
button to be right here to fit the whole
middle or one half of the screen so this
button needs to be on one half of the
screen so that when we run our game we
have a button right here that we can
click on now this is very ugly we don't
want it to look like this so first
things first remove the text from the
button we're also gonna rename this one
to jump BTN so Jumby T and this is the
name of the button and inside of the
inspector panel of the button here we
have the color we're gonna click on it
which is gonna open this pop-up window
and we are gonna set the Alpha to zero
you see which is gonna make the button
transparent it is still clickable but
it's not visible so now we need to go
here before we start typing anything we
need to type using Unity engine UI
because the button is under this UI if
we don't type it out we will not be able
to get the button and we need to get it
in order for us to program it for it to
do something so what we need is a
private animator which I'm gonna call an
M we also need a private boolean on left
on right and a private boolean a private
bull jumped jumped like this inside of
the awake function we are gonna well
initialize these variables so in the
awake here
we are gonna say an M is equal to get
component to get the animator component
that is attached on the player and we
also need to get a reference to our
button but before that I'm gonna see
here on write is equal to true on left
is equal to false this is to initialize
on left and on right
these on left and on right are gonna
determine the side on which we are so
it's going to determine if we are
currently on the right side or on the
left side and this is for the jump
animation so we will deal with this in a
moment don't worry about that what we
need to do is create here a function so
public void jump and this is the
function that's gonna allow us to jump
and we need to add it to the button by
typing here game object find the game
object with the name jump BT and like
this so if I go here in our unity editor
we see that we named our jump button
jump BTN so that's the same thing we
need to type right here now pay close
attention this name right here that you
put so jump BT and this run right here
needs to match up with this right here
if you make a mistake this will not work
but we need the button and we are gonna
get it as a component so get component
button like this dot on click dock add
listener and this listener takes a
function name so the function name is
jump which means that now we added jump
to the button which is the function and
it'll be executed when we click on the
button just so that I can well
confirm my claims I'm gonna see here
printed something like this it's not
important but important is that we see
that when we click on the button this
jump function right here will be called
in the console we're gonna see all of
that let me just go here and clear it if
I hit the play button
if I click somewhere here Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam you see here printed is being
printed in the console which means that
actually this worked so now our public
voice jump is the function that's gonna
be executed when we well hit the button
so what you're gonna do in this jump
function well first we are gonna see
here if on right so if we are on the
right side when we press the jump button
we're gonna call our atom to play the
jump left animation like this else if we
are not on the right side which means we
are on the left side we're gonna call
our atom to play jump right and below
here we're gonna inform that we have
jumped so jumped is now equal to true
while we're doing all of that well the
reason for it is because in the update
function right here you're gonna test if
we did not jump so if we currently did
not jump that means we are moving either
on the left side or on the right side so
we're gonna test
are we moving on the right see if on
right meaning we are moving on the right
side we're gonna call our atom to play
run a write animation else our atom is
gonna play the run left animation like
this so as simple as that but we are
still not done because we need to go
here in our unity select the player here
so select the player and go here we have
jump left we need to duplicate it and
now we need to rename it to jump right
so now we need to rename it as I said to
jump right but what we also need to do
is we need to set here the speed
be- y- well because when we use jump
left it will jump from the right to the
left side but now we have duplicated
that same animation which means that if
we call jump right it will again make
the player jump from the right to the
left but we need need him to you well
jump from left to right that's why we
are going to use the negative we will
see this in a second now before we
continue actually do anything we do need
to well we do need to we need to add one
more feature to our animations so in the
animation panel right here we have our
player and here we have his jump left
and jump right animation let me just go
here inside of our assets then inside of
our animations right here player
animations here it is we have jump left
run left and run right I'm need to
duplicate this jump left and call it
jump right because we need to be able to
see this animation right here so we need
to be able to see this animation right
here we currently don't see it because
we have here jump left which uses jump
left motion which is the animation so
it's the animation itself jump right
uses that same motion we need to select
jump right and select here jump right
you see this one right here the one that
we have just duplicated it's the same
animation but we will play it backwards
now as I said the reason why we need to
do this is because we need to be able to
see this animation you see we need to be
able to see it right here because we
have the player jump left which is this
one right here and let me just go here
we have jump right actually yeah here it
is
sprite just take a look at it so this is
jump right actually it needs to be
duplicated yeah it will be when we well
go into code so don't worry about that
what we need to do here is take the jump
left and go here on the last frame click
on this keyframe you see this right here
this is while a motion or an event
function event that we are adding at the
last frame
and that is gonna be a function that we
need you will create inside of our
script so right here below our public
void jump you're gonna have void on left
and we're gonna have void on right so I
left and on right in on left we're gonna
see on left is equal to true on right is
equal to false and jumped is equal to u
true or actually false again copy all of
this here in on right we're gonna do
well the opposite on left is false on
right is true and jumped will be equal
to false so if we go back in unity and
here select that event so that you can
see it like this as I see it in the
inspector panel so now you have a
function to select so I'm gonna select
here this is jump left animation so we
have the jump left here we are gonna
call on left as you can see here we need
to call on the left and for the right
animation so for the right one we need
to call on right so if I go here we have
run actually this is not run jump right
here it is jump right we need to add
that event here at the beginning why at
the beginning well because we're gonna
play this animation and backwards we
will see this in a second so if I hit
here add the keyframe click on it so you
need to click the keyframe and select
the function on the right so now we are
good to go to test all of this out and
then I will explain it again line by
line and what is going on so if I hit
the play button you see here I hit the
play button if I click here to jump we
will go to this animations we just saw
go here as you can see now we have a
problem that problem is the following
because this jump right needs to well
have this loop time on check actually
this one right here too so let me just
run right run left let me just see what
is the problem here so we have on right
on left is false on right is true
and jumped well be equal to false this
is what we did and I think this is okay
so let me just go back here in the
animation jump right here is our
animation on right it's calling on right
this should work so I'm gonna just go
here hit the play button okay yeah now
it's working I don't know why I did not
work a moment ago but the important
thing is well let me just take the jump
left
did I turn off loop time so turn off the
loop time from jump left and also turn
off loop time from jump right and let me
just test it out again yeah the problem
was the loop time now what is loop time
and how do you actually deactivate it
well
double-click on the animation you will
have these options here to deactivate
the loop time loop time it will make
that animation loop over and over and
over again so we do not want that let me
now explain what is going on let me hit
the play button you see our game is
running the player is running on the
right side which means that our run
right animation is being played when we
run the game the awake function will be
called now here we are getting the jump
button adding the listener which means
the function that will be executed when
we press the button and we are getting
the component animator but we are also
setting on the right side to be true on
left is false
because initially when we run the game
our player is on the right side in the
update function if we did not jump the
default value of a boolean is false if
we don't type here if we don't type here
like this we don't type is equal to true
the default value will be false so if we
did not jump before so if we did not
jump this is false that means we are
running so if we are on the right side
we will play the run right animation if
we are on the left side we will play a
run left when we jump if we are on the
right side we will jump to the left side
otherwise if we are not on the right
meaning we are on the Left will jump to
the right side so what is going on yeah
jump to the right
confusable right left up and downs on
and so forth we also created events so
animation events here inside of the
animation itself you see here we have
created these which means these events
will be called when the animation hits
that frame you see when the animation
hits that frame it will call that event
which is actually this function so when
we get to the last frame in this case we
are playing the animation backwards and
when I say backwards if I set this to be
negative or actually 22.5 notice what's
gonna happen so we are gonna jump really
see you see what is happening
you see which problem do we have here
because we are not playing that
animation backwards we are not playing
that animation back where is this jump
right and in order to play it backwards
we simply need to set the negative to
the speed because we are using the jump
left animation you see the motion is
from the jump
left we just duplicated renamed it to
jump right which means that is the same
animation if you want to play backwards
set the speed to negative it will start
playing it from the back so it will not
start from the front or the beginning of
the animation it will start from the
back which means from here it will start
from here and go to here which means
that the first frame will actually be
the last frame because we're playing
from backwards when I say from backwards
if we have here 60 frames that means
backwards we will play from frame 60 to
frame zero so frame zero is the last
frame and here is where we are putting
the on right
this one right here function to be
called which means we are not on the
left side anymore we are on the right
side and we did not jump so when the
animation ends it calls this event and
these get executed jump is false and
when the jump is false notice
exclamation mark will make what's after
after in the opposite so jumped here is
false but the exclamation mark here is
making it true because it's making the
opposite what's opposite of false it's
true so if we did not jump and we are on
the right side play the run right
animation if we did not jump and we are
on the right side meaning we're on the
left side play the run left animation
when we jump if we are on the right side
that means jump to the left side when we
jump and we are not on the right side
that means we are on the left side then
play jump right so jump to the right
side and as you can see here jumped is
true because while we are in the air we
don't want to play run right or run a
left animation as you can see with a
couple of lines of code these are not
that many lines of code these are 20 or
so lines of code we managed to make our
player jump from the left to the right
but if we did all of this in our code we
will need to calculate where the player
is when he lands how we are gonna
animate him so it's gonna or that would
be complicated but like this it's very
very simple you see the players jumping
from left to right and right to left
with just a couple of lines of code as
you see right here so it's really easy
to do this with animations and we don't
have to do anything complicated now we
can also use space and just take this
right here so all of this right here and
inside of our update right below where
we are testing if we did if we did not
jump we can test if so if input get key
down key code space so space if we press
the space key on our keyboard we're
gonna do the same thing right here so
that same thing is actually jump and we
can test it out so if I go back here hit
the play button I'm hitting space now
and I'm jumping you see hitting space
and jumping hitting space and jumping
heating space and jumping then you get
my point and you can watch these
animations being played right here
notice when we run the game you see
Ronna right is being played when I job
you see jump from the left or jump from
the right to the left
animation played and it is indicated
with this bar right here you see the
blue thing that is filling this is the
bar indicating which animation is the
plate so now we are on the left side
because we triggered we have triggered
on left on left is true on right is
false and when on right is false as you
can see here we're gonna play run left
which animation is playing around left
when we jump
you see we jump from left to right and
the jump right animation was being
played because when we jump we're
testing if we are not on the right side
that means we are on the left jump to
the right side
let us add our first obstacle in the
game so we need to go into sprites and
then enemies and obstacles the first one
is gonna be our flag so simply drag and
drop the flag right here and for this
flag what we need to do is set the scale
on the x-axis at 1.23 now this flag is
not gonna be on its own we are also
gonna have the squirrel or the squirrel
and we're gonna add it as a child of the
flag so before we create the animation
of the squirrel as you can see we have
four animations or one two three four
yes four animations from the squirrel we
are going to take the flag and we're
gonna add a box Collider 2d on it now
you can see that the box Collider is all
around this flag we don't want it to be
like this instead we are gonna resize
that box Collider so the size on the x
axis can be 1024 the size on the Y is
gonna be point 52 and I'm gonna set the
offset Y to be at point zero six so this
is this green thing do you see this
green rectangle thing this is our
Collider that is on the flag itself so
now we can select our squirrel and we
can create it now before we actually
create the squirrel squirrel we will
create a folder inside of the animation
so assets animations right-click create
a new folder just is going to be our
squirrel animation so it's
sq I RR e
Skua and we are gonna create the
animation for our squirrel so sprites
enemies select all four of these drag
and drop the squirrel here BAM
here it is and I'm gonna save it into
animations and then squirrel and here it
is squirrel like this animation and hit
enter as you can see the squirrel is too
big if I put it right here and go into
the game tab it is bigger than the
player itself so we do not want that
what we want to do is we want to resize
the squirrel so we are gonna see points
4 on the x + 4 point 4 on the y 4 x + y
scale we're also gonna add a box
Collider 2d on the squirrel and resize
it because currently it is all over the
squirrel so the size on the X is gonna
be 1 point
terney 9 and the size on the Y is gonna
be 0.88 and we're also gonna offset it
so offset on X is going to be negative
point 28 and offset on the y is gonna be
0.7 teen now we also need to add a
rigidbody on the squirrel so here I'm
gonna go add component a rigid body 2d
on the scroll I'm gonna attach it I'm
not gonna set it to be kinematic I'm
gonna leave it a dynamic and also what
we want to do is we want to add that
squirrel to be the child of our flag
because the flag and the squirrel go
well one with each one with another
let me just rename the squirrel here in
the hierarchy as squirrel and I'm gonna
well put it to be under the flag let me
just set it at zero for the x-axis and
for the y-axis I'm gonna reposition it
something like this but since gravity is
being applied on the squirrel it will be
well it will fall down on the flag
itself now in regards to the flag when
we set it to be at position zero for the
x axis this is how it looks like we are
also going to take the flag set it at
negative three we
for the Z does this work actually it
needs to be at three not negative three
so set it to be at three so that it is
like this you see it's behind our
obstacles now one thing that we want to
do is you see when we run the game
notice what's happening here so you see
we have the flag and it's going or not
going down we will cover that in a
moment but we also want the squirrel
squirrel to move left and right and in
order for the squirrel to move left and
right we need to create well a script
for our squirrel so if we go inside of
our assets scripts right click create
new folder enemy scripts this is where
we are gonna put our enemy script
well the folder and here I'm gonna right
click and create a new folder and I'm
gonna see here squirrel so sq I are evil
or are ya P Elia that it is sometimes I
don't know how to spell so forgive me
right-click create a c-sharp script
squirrel and attach it on the squirrel
itself so something like this attach it
on the squirrel double-click it and open
it in monodevelop let me just hold enter
actually for a stagette class hold enter
just to give a little bit of space and
if we go here on top we are gonna add
some variables the first one is going to
be a private float move speed which by
default is gonna be equal to 3 and we
need update we don't need the start
function so we're not gonna initialize
anything but we need to create a
function that's actually gonna move the
squirrel so here I'm gonna say void move
and we're gonna use the same technique
as we did with our backgrounds so what
we want to do here is create a vector3
temporary position which is equal to
transform position and here we're gonna
say temp that x plus equals speed
multiplied with time dot delta time and
simply take the transform position is
now equal to you temp if we put this
function right here in the
update it will start moving the squirrel
but we will have one problem so if we go
back here and run it you see the problem
the squirrel is trying to go away here
and trying to touch things and whatnot
but it is not working so that's not
working and why isn't working well
because we're just moving the squirrel
to the right side plus equals to you is
the same thing as if we say temp dot X
is equal to temp dot X plus moves be
multiplied time that so it's time that
delta x we just type it out correctly
here time dot time.deltatime finally
thank you very much so this right here
is the same thing as writing this here
but this is a shortcut plus equals two
we don't need to type well like this as
you just see here now what we need to do
we need to detect when we touch our
bounds and since both of our bounds so
if we go here and if I select the side
boundaries you see the box collider
actually the box Collider that is
attached on them is not set to be a
trigger if we select the squirrel the
box Collider attached on the squirrel is
not set to be a trigger so we cannot use
on trigger enter instead we need to use
here void on collision enter 2d which
takes a collision 2d as an argument and
I'm gonna going to call it target so
this on collision enter will be called
when two colliders touch each other so
when the squirrel touches this side of
the bound on collision enter will be
called or if it touches the left side on
collision enter will be called what we
want to test here is if the squirrel has
touched the side bounce so we are gonna
see here if targets so target which is
this parameter right here so this is the
target parameter collision 2d that's
passed inside of this function which
enables us to get information about
collisions such as the game object we
have collided with so if the target dot
game object and it's tag is equal to
side bound so if
equal to side bounce we have touched our
bounds now we need to go in our unity
editor go inside of our tags so go on
top here it is we have side bound so
here if we select all of these they are
tagged as side bound so not side bounce
but its side bounce so don't add s or
otherwise it will not work I was just
going over to my unity energy to make
sure which tag we have applied and if I
left it its bounce with s plural not
singular then BAM we have a problem so
this name right here in the tag this
name right here needs to match up with
the name right here or otherwise it will
not work so if we have collided with our
side bounce what we want to do we'll
simply we want to change direction so
we're gonna say here move speed will be
multiplied by negative 1 so multiply 2
by negative 1 which will change the
value of the speed what does that mean
well that means that if the speed was
positive now it will be negative if the
speed was negative now it will be
positive so every time we touch one side
it will make the speed either positive
or negative and it will make our
squirrel go into the left or the right
side let me demonstrate that and we will
have one problem that we will see and
fix so notice now the squirrel is going
back what you see the squirrel is going
left and right going left and right let
me just zooming how can I do this never
mind you can see what I mean so you see
the squirrel is going left and right
left and right you see left right left
right now the problem here is that the
scroll is not changing the direction
where it is facing so what we need to do
here is create a vector3 temporary
variable which is equal to you transform
that a local scale and temporary
variable X which is while the scale or
the direction on the x axis we are going
to multiply that so multiplied equal to
by negative 1 and the reason for it is
the same thing we are gonna change the
direction if the scale is now positive
it will be negative so notice what I
mean so if I go here in the scene and
zoom in you see what the scroll hits
this side it's gonna go ink so when it
hits the right side is gonna start to go
to the left side and it needs to face
the left side so that means that the
squirrel and let me just type here point
four that means that the squirrel will
now be facing the left side which is the
negative you see like this the negative
this is the positive negative positive
or negative it will simply change the
direction where it is facing by
multiplying this with negative one so
now transform local scale is equal to
temp and we can now go back in our unity
editor and test to see if the squirrel
will change directions of BAM it is
changing the direction BAM changing
direction BAM it is in fact now changing
the direction what it hits the bounce
now one more thing that we need to do is
for the flag itself so here in the enemy
scripts I'm gonna create a new c-sharp
script which I'm going to call enemy
move and this one we're gonna attach it
on the flag itself so you see the flag
itself it needs to move down same way as
our bounds are moving down so if we go
here in the enemy move function let me
just are actually script excuse me so
here I'm going to tag it with the class
tag hold ENTER to give a little bit of
space here on top we need to have a
public float move speed which is going
to be equal to one F we also need a
private float which is going to be
camera Y and inside of our start
function we're gonna say camera Y is
equal to camera so camera that main dot
transform that position that Y and let's
say -10 F just so that we well know from
where we need to turn off our game
object now notice this or what we need
to do now is that we need to type void
move which is a function that's gonna
move our game object and we're gonna
call move in the update
we're gonna do the same thing as we did
with our BG mover so vector3 tempest
transform.position our temp dot Y is
minus equals to move speed multiplied
with time dot delta time and transform
position is now equal to10 reassigning
it back so this is nothing new it will
simply move the game object down we did
this already but in our void deactivate
so deactivate we are simply going to
test if transform that position that Y
is less than cameras Y then what we want
to do is we want to say game object set
active Falls to deactivate the game
object from our game we're gonna call it
right below the update so we are gonna
test if our own Y position so the Y
position of the enemy move which is
attached on the flag itself if it's less
than the cameras Y that we have
calculated here then we will deactivate
our game object deactivating the game
object releases memory in our game
because we are getting rid of game
objects that we don't need we don't need
them in terms of when this flag goes
down so if the flag goes down like this
we don't need it anymore because it's
out of sight we don't eat it the player
does not see it it's not important to us
and because of that well we need to get
rid of it the simplest way is to use set
active false which means the game object
will be deactivated that means notice if
I select the flag and notice here in the
inspector we have this cube icon right
next to it we have a check box and then
we have the name of the game object if I
uncheck this check box BAM you see the
game object is no more it's not visible
in the scene view and it's not visible
in the game view which means it is
deactivated it is still in the hierarchy
here we could potentially activate it
again if we have a reference to it but
when it's not active all scripts that
are attached on this game object will
not work all scripts that are collisions
physics that is applied to this game
object will not be calculated when the
game object is not active now we do need
to set the move speed to five because it
needs to be the same speed as our side
boundaries so that they move in the same
harmony so to say so if I hit the play
but now notice it is moving down you see
BAM it is moving down and we well
touched our squirrel with the player let
me just take the player here and
actually the player can be set to be a
trigger and I'm gonna hit apply because
anyways we set him to be kinematic so he
can set to be a trigger so that we don't
roll over game objects as we just did
with our squirrel so if I hit the play
button again notice bam the game object
is going down and notice now when it
goes actually got deactivated so let me
try this again in the scene notice when
it goes down here BAM it is deactivated
and we don't need it in the game any
more so this was our first obstacle we
will have more obstacles but before we
proceed to create more obstacles we are
gonna create functionality in our side
script or speedy mover script to spawn
these obstacles on random so we will see
that starting from the next video but
before we finish this one here in the
prefabs folder create a new folder for
enemy prefabs like this and drag and
drop the flag right here now the flag
has this scroll as a child game objects
which will be dragged along with it but
create a free prefab out of it because
we're gonna use the prefab to spawn that
game object in RC so now what we want to
do is create the functionality inside of
our BG mover script so this one right
here so that it spawns obstacles when it
repositions the balance but before that
what I'm gonna do is select the side
boundaries and create an empty game
object which is going to be the child
offside boundaries and I am simply gonna
set its position at 3.5 and this is
gonna be the right
spawners so this is gonna be the right
spawner or this is where we are gonna
spawn our obstacles on the right side
I'm just quickly gonna tag it here with
this tag so it is available right here
when you click on this icon so let me
just select none and you see this cube
icon right here you can click on it and
select one of these icons so I'm gonna
tag it like this duplicate it and this
is gonna be the left spawner so this one
instead of right it's gonna be left and
I'm gonna set it at X negative 3.5 and
tag it with the orange one I'm also
going to select both of these and set
their z axis at negative two so now I'm
gonna duplicate them and simply put them
right here to be below our side
boundaries 1 now their x-axis is going
to be the same Y axis will be set to
zero so select both of these set the y
axis to 0 so that it moves them right
here above or where our next boundaries
are so I'm going to duplicate these now
and put them below side boundaries too
and I am gonna rename it just right and
left spawner and I am gonna select them
set the y axis at 0 so that they go
right here and again duplicate these two
and put them right below side boundaries
3 let me just rename them side spawner
like this below this one side spawner
and I am gonna put them at Y to be equal
to 0 X is gonna be the same so for the
right spawner it will be 3.5 for the
left spawner negative 3.5 and their
y-axis will be the same which will make
them at the exact same position under
every parent game object so now we can
go inside of our script which is BG
mover and right here on the top we can
create a public so public game object
array of enemies and a public game
object array of spawn positions this is
where we are gonna dry
can drop our enemies and where we are
gonna drag and drop our well spawn
positions so before we continue we need
to do just that
select side boundaries and here for
spawn positions set the size to to drag
and drop the left and the right spawner
now in element 0 first you're gonna put
the right spawner so element 0 will be
right spawner than the left spawner now
for side boundaries 1 2 & 3
we're also gonna set the sides or spawn
position size 2
now don't put these so you see this
right spawner here don't put it to be
right here for the side boundaries 1 so
don't put them right there you need to
put their appropriate children so right
spawner that is under side boundaries 1
will go here and left spawner will be
here and for the side boundaries - it's
right spawner will be here pay attention
which ones I'm dragging so that you
don't make a mistake and this one I'm
gonna put right here side boundaries and
here I'm gonna put the right spawner and
here I'm gonna put his left spawner so
they're appropriate children this is
really important don't mix it up don't
put this right spawner to be right here
for the side boundaries 3 put the
appropriate spawners for the appropriate
parents now I'm also gonna select site
boundaries all 4 of them so 1 2 & 3 and
side boundaries and here for the enemies
we're gonna set the size to 1 because
currently we only have the flag enemy so
I'm gonna click on this little circle
here and well select the flag enemy
which is our current obstacle that we
have or the only obstacle that we
currently have so what are we gonna do
now we're gonna go here inside of the BG
mover and right here below our
reposition script we are gonna say void
spawn enemies now the spawn enemies will
be called right here so right below when
we reposition so when we reposition our
ops
are actually the boundaries when we
reposition them up we will spawn enemies
and we're gonna call here spawn enemies
like this now we're gonna use a random
value to determine if we are gonna spawn
these enemies so we're gonna say if
random that range from 0 up to 10 if
it's greater than 0 now first of all
this right here is gonna be frequency of
spawning enemies and it's not spelled
like this so it's frequency of spawning
enemies now notice here I said if it's
greater than zero every time this will
be greater than zero all that is 1 by 10
chance that it will not be greater than
zero so it means that every time it will
spawn enemies but if you want you will
set less chance for enemies to be
spawned right away you can save 5 so
that's 50/50 chance for enemies to be
spawned 3 that is 70 by 30 chance for
Lana needs to be spawned 7 that is 30 by
70 chance that the enemies will be
spawned but for testing purposes I'm
gonna say here zero because we need to
test right away
if this is actually working so what
we're gonna do here well first you're
gonna say int random enemy he's gonna be
equal to a random that range from 0 up
to enemies that linked this will give us
a random index from 0 up to our arrays
length because we're gonna use our
enemies array this one right here to
spawn our enemies and on random we will
spawn while these enemies now since our
flag enemy so the flag one with the
squirrel that we created in the previous
video is the only obstacle that needs to
be spawn in the middle and we set that
obstacle to be at element well 0 so it's
at index 0 for all 4 of our boundaries
the flag is at element 0 which means
that here we can test if our random
enemy which is the index and here we can
say random enemy index just so that we
don't get confused so random enemy
index is equal to zero then we know that
this is the flag enemy flag enemy and
the flag enemy here I'm gonna say -
needs to be spawned in the middle so
what you're gonna do here is you're
simply gonna call instantiate and we're
gonna instantiate the enemies the enemy
that's at the random enemy index and we
are gonna instantiate it by using new
vector3 so new vector3
like this 0 for the x because it needs
to be spawned in the middle trance from
that position that y for the y and 3 f
for the z axis and for our rotation
we're gonna say quaternion identity like
this and just hit enter so that it goes
right here on this line else here if
it's not so if the random index is not
equal to 0 that means that it's not our
flag so others or other game objects
will be spawned on the left spawner and
the right spawner but we will call code
that later on now we're gonna test our
flag if it's actually working so if we
go back here hit the play button and if
I go here on the scene you see when we
respawn our obstacle you see BAM here we
have an Bam and bam and bam
every time we will have these obstacles
which are the flags that are being
spawned right here and when they go down
you see when they go down here that will
be deactivated so every time they go
down they will be deactivated and as you
see since I set here if this random
range is greater than 0 every time we
see that enemy is being spawned and the
reason for it because from 0 up to 10
that is 1 by 9 chance that we will get
something greater than 0 but if you want
to spawn enemies less frequently you can
say for example 4 that is 60 by 40
chance that the enemies will be spawned
five that is 50-50 chance so and and so
for you get my point and here as I
already explained because our flag is
set on index 0 and we want the flag to
be spawn
the middle that's the only obstacle that
will be spawned in the middle and
because of that as I already said we are
doing it like this so in the else
statement right here we will spawn all
our other obstacles and we will either
spawn them here on the right spawner
side or on the left spawner side but
before we can actually do that we need
to create these obstacles and program
those obstacles with product we need to
go into sprites and then enemies and
obstacles the first one will be our tree
that you are gonna add but it's too big
as you can see here it's trees illa so
you can kill our our ninja just by
adding it to the scene so what we need
to do is we need to change its scale so
for the scale X I'm gonna say point 4
point 4 for device so this is well how
we are gonna use it I'm satisfied with
this height or how large our tree is
we're gonna attach a box Collider 2d on
it now we are not gonna leave it like
this as you see we are gonna rescale it
so the size on the X is gonna be 4 point
43 and the size on the Y is gonna be
3.44 of course we are gonna well offset
it so the offset X is gonna be point 51
and the offset y is gonna be negative
1.3 or actually we can leave it at
negative 1 so negative 1 can be the
offset for our tree we are gonna create
attack for the tree so we're gonna click
on add tag click on the plus button here
and we're gonna see here enemy tree and
hit enter select the tree here in the
hierarchy and we are gonna see here or
select the enemy tree tag so this is our
enemy tree we are also gonna have our
enemy ninja which is this dude right
here who is also a ninja Zilla
so yeah we're gonna resize him of course
so for the ninja enemy we're gonna say
point 25 for the X point 25 for the Y
and we are gonna add a box Collider 2d
component on him of course you're gonna
resize and not leave it
like this so the size on the X is right
here and we're gonna save 1.99 or
actually we're gonna save point -
actually - not to point you so - for the
size on the x size on the y is gonna be
lets say 5.38 and offset x is gonna be
one point any one offset y is gonna be
point 62 and voila
here is our and a meat ninja and we are
gonna set him to be a trigger so you're
gonna make him to be a trigger and we're
also gonna tag him so here we're gonna
add a tag which I'm simply gonna call
enemy and I'm gonna click Save
select the ninja enemy and I am gonna
well tag him with the enemy tag the last
enemy that we have is our B but our B as
you can see here well we have how many
eight of these B's so how can we add
them because if you drag and drop the be
like this this is not what we want to
have in our game so select the be right
here in sprites enemies and obstacles
and you see here in the inspector panel
we have the sprite mode this is a
drop-down list so we have single
multiple and polygons currently it is
set to single which means unity is
treating this image or this asset as a
single image but we need to have these
bees separated in order to have them
separated
we are gonna select multiple instead of
single let me hit apply here at the
bottom so that this change applies to
this image and now we're gonna click on
a sprite editor which is going to open
this thing that you see right here this
is the sprite editor where we can slice
each individual bee by itself because
this or these bees are a sequence of
animations unity can slice this well on
its own but you can drag or you can
simply draw you see here I just drew
this rectangle with well left clicking
and drawing it and while out there it is
in order to delete it hold command press
D on windows control and delete actually
I said D but it's backwards or that
delete so control the lead on Mac
command and button above enter but unity
can slice is pretty good on its own by
simply clicking here slice you see we
have the sprite editor and if you click
on the slice here it's gonna say
automatic so we want to allow unity to
you sliced or detect automatically where
it needs to slice things pivot will be
the center and I'm gonna click slice and
bam here it is so you see unity can
slice this pretty good on its own but
sometimes it needs a little bit of help
so as you can see here we can resize
these because we're not gonna leave it
like this here we're gonna resize it a
little bit something like this and
select this one also resize it right
here and on well down
let me just like this one this one is
okay the third one let me see where it
is just a little bit here you can simply
well read rag these as you can see to
resize them just so that it fits the B
and it does not go outside of the B so
something like this well do select this
one okay we need to move this back now
as I said unity is pretty good at
slicing things but sometimes it needs
help from us as you can see right here
and this one also is the last one like
this and we are good to go
and I'm gonna hit apply so when
everything here is done you see you can
hit apply which is right here and these
changes will be applied to this image so
now when we click on the drop-down list
of this image we can select these bees
now by accident unity has added
somewhere another slice which is well
this empty image so ignore the first
part I'm not gonna go back so you will
need to go back here and search where
that slice is well actually it's here
what will font we've found it right away
so select it and delete it if you don't
find it it's well not a problem and I
can hit apply now and bam here we are as
I said this is not a problem even if
it's there just ignore it don't take the
first image but select all other images
as you can see here B from 1 up to 9
drag and drop the B right here in our
well scene view and go into animations
to save that animation you folder B
animation I'm gonna hit and
and Here I am gonna say be animation
it's not like you need to be the
animation but this is the B animation so
B let me just rename it here to be in
our hierarchy panel and I am gonna
rescale it so the scale is gonna be 0.4
0.4 4 X and the y we are gonna add a
component on it so it's gonna be a box
Collider 2d and of course we are not
gonna resize it this time I said of
course but actually yeah we're not gonna
resize it this time I'm pretty satisfied
with the result right here maybe we can
resize it a little bit to be smaller but
that we can test that later on to see if
there is a need to do so and here we're
also gonna attach a rigidbody 2d and we
are gonna make in kinematic so here
we're gonna say kinematic and we're
gonna tag the B as the enemy so tag the
B as the enemy and voila we are done we
need to go here into the prefabs enemy
prefabs so drag and drop the tree drag
and drop the enemy drag and drop the B
and select our spawners or side
boundaries so select all four of these
and now for the enemy size we are gonna
set well we have four enemies so we're
gonna set size to four so now I'm gonna
drag and drop the B drag and drop the
ninja enemy and drag and drop the tree
we don't have to do anything else except
attach a script to move our enemies but
we will see that in a second we can now
safely delete him here from the scene if
I hit the play button now as you can see
here if I hit the play button actually
yeah I was why I was tripping that we
actually coded we need to code the
spawning of our other enemies so yeah I
was tripping that we have already coded
that so sorry for that we have attached
our enemies now else if our random enemy
index is not equal to one if it's equal
to 1 we will spawn the flag in the
middle else if it's not equal to 1 or 0
excuse me we are gonna create a new game
object which I'm gonna call enemy obj
which is gonna be equal to instantiate
enemies
inside of it we are gonna see random
enemy index like this we are also gonna
see here vector 3 which is gonna be our
enemies scale which is going to be equal
to enemy obj dot a local scale so
actually enemy obj dot transform that
local scale and now we are gonna
determine are we gonna spawn that enemy
on the left or on the right so we're
gonna see here if our random dot range
from zero to two if it's greater than
zero so it's a 50-50 chance to spawn
this game object or position it either
on the left or on the right so here
we're gonna spawn it right so we're
gonna see here enemy obj that transform
that position is going to be equal to u
spawn positions and the position that's
add the zero index so here I gonna say
transform position because the position
that is at the zero index we set it to
be the right spotter if you remember so
this you need to double check to make
sure but the right spawner should be at
element zero so right spawner and also
here right spawner and also here right
spawner so the right spawner is on index
zero so here we are using index zero we
are also gonna take the enemy obj so
enemy obj dot scale or actually here
enemy scale that X is gonna be equal to
negative of Matt AB absolute value of
enemy enemy scale that X why is it like
this what we need to make sure that our
enemies are also facing the correct side
we don't want our enemy to be for
example here so we don't want our enemy
like if I take the player and pretend
that he is the enemy I don't want the
enemy to be here like this instead I
want him to be here like this so I want
him to face the correct side and if well
in order to do that we need to change
the scale and we already explained that
we are changing the scale to make the
game object face the correct side else
if the rank
rage is not greater than zero this one
right here we are gonna spawn it to the
left to the left so spawn left so here
we're gonna say enemy obj but let me
just copy and paste this right here so
enemy obj transform position is going to
be equal to spawn positions and the
index that's add or element that's an
index one which is the left spawner and
here we are not gonna use the negative
but we're gonna use the positive of the
scale X to make the game object face the
correct side and the last thing that we
need to do is take the enemy obj that
transform that a local scale to be equal
to enemy skill because while this is
gonna face the enemy in the correct
direction let me go back here in unity
and what we need to do here let me just
clear the console we are gonna test it
out now so if I hit the play button we
are gonna see our enemies being spawned
but we're also gonna see one problem you
see the B it is spawned the ninja is
also spawn but what is happening well
they're not moving down so we need to go
here select the B ninja enemy and the
tree and attach enemy move script set
the move speed to five and if I hit the
play button now we will see that they
are being spawned and going down you see
we have our flag now over there is the
tree so if I go back here BAM here is
the tree we just pass it here is the B
here is the tree again let's hope to see
the ninja here is the ninja and you see
that depending on where he is spawn beat
that left or right you see the B now is
facing the correct side here on the Left
B's facing the correct side let's see
the ninja do we have the ninja so we
have here C ninja clone but let's hope
he's on the right side well he is not
but anyways yeah this one is you see he
is facing the correct side which is the
effect that we achieved by using this
right here and this right here and then
assigning it to the scale of our enemy
obj that we have spawned right here now
one thing that we are gonna do is the
following
our tree is gonna have the enemy move
script but the B and the ninja enemy are
gonna have different scripts they're
gonna move them down but they're also
gonna make the B attack our player and
the ninja also it will make them attack
the player so we need to code that with
a separate script I just put these enemy
move scripts on them so that we can
demonstrate that this actually works and
that we have enemies spawned in our game
so if we go inside of our scripts folder
we have enemy scripts here we are gonna
add our B scripts so I'm gonna create a
folder B scripts because we have one for
the squirrel as you can see here
squirrel well I'm just cool whisper wha
and Here I am gonna name this one B
script so right click create a new
script named it B script before I open
it I'm gonna go and attach it on the B
itself so remove the enemy move script
we don't need it we are gonna attach the
B script on the B itself simply by
clicking add component and while
filtering here for the B script and if
you want to remove a component that is
attached on a game object you have this
gear icon on it where you can click on
remove component double click on the B
script and voila here it is so I'm gonna
see here class and I am gonna tag the
class at the bottom and hold ENTER to
give a little bit of space let me just
see here what did I click it's not
pouring
anyways moving forward as always we need
a couple of variables so we need a
public float move speed which might be
fault I'm gonna say 3.5 F now what is
the behavior that we actually want from
our B well if I go here in the B prefabs
enemy prefabs B here it is what I want
from the B is the following
I want the B to go here until it's Y
position is 0 so until Y position is 0
it will stop here and it will try to
attack the player something like this or
like this or like this it's not
important but it will try to attack the
player so for that we need a couple of
variables we need a private boolean so
private ball attack start it we also
need pry
bull move and attack we also need a
private bull private bull attack right
this is gonna determine if we are
attacking from the right side or the
left side so are we attacking to the
right or are we attacking to the left
side we also need a private float which
is going to be our attack speed by
default I'm gonna set it to be equal to
six now in the start function when we
first spawn the B we want to determine
do we attack to the right or do we
attack to the left and we're going to
determine that by using transform
position X if it's greater than zero
that means we are on the left side or
actually we are on the right side and we
will attack to the left because notice
here I'm gonna take the player as an
example so I have the player if I set
his X to be zero he's in the middle if
the X is at two he is to the right side
because in unity x axis goes positive so
it's something like this so I'm gonna
see here highlight tool we have the
coordinate system and this is X and this
is y for those of you who don't know so
x axis going in this direction it's the
positive direction going in this
direction
it's the negative direction for the y
axis going up that's the positive side
and going down that's the negative side
and here right here at the axis that is
zero so I'm testing here if the
transform position X is greater than
zero what does this tell you so if it's
zero it's right in the middle if it's
greater than zero that means we are on
the right side so we are in the positive
side so when the B attacks is going to
attack to the left side and not in the
right side if the transform position X
is not greater than zero that means we
need to attack to the right side so here
we are gonna say attack so attack right
is equal to false because we're
attacking to the left side else
if the transform position X is greater
then or actually lower than zero then
attack right is going to be equal to
true because I already explained if it's
lower than zero that means we're in the
left side which is the negative side so
now below the update function we're
gonna create void be a tag function so
be attack and we're gonna call this one
inside of the update function this is
where the magic happens this is where we
are gonna attack so what we're gonna do
here we're gonna move the beat downwards
until its position is greater than zero
so we're gonna say as long as or if our
transform position Y is greater than 0
which means the B is still not in the
middle of the screen and again I'm going
to take the highlight tool and
demonstrate that so again we have the X
and the y so here we have Y and here we
have X I said upwards on the Y is the
positive size so plus here right here
where the X is this is zero so if the B
is here that means the transform
position Y is greater than zero because
you see zero is here and our position is
here that means we are greater so
position Y is greater than zero and as
long as the transform position Y from
the B is greater than zero we are gonna
move the B downward so when the B hits
zero position or below zero somewhere
around here as long as the Y position is
not greater than zero anymore
we will not move the B so what we're
going to do here we are gonna say
vector3 temp is equal to transform that
position temp dot y minus equals move
speed multiplied with time.deltatime and
transform position is equal to temp
again and we can test it out if we go
back here since we have a tag script on
the B if I simply run the game let us
wait for the B to be spawned so here we
have the player flag has been spawned
next one is ninja enemy ninja enemy
again come on please spawned the B spawn
the B we have the
freak loan come on here it is so the B
has been spawned and notice now the B is
gonna go down until it reaches here is
the B BAM it reached zero you see it
reached zero for the Y and it's not
moving anymore because its position now
is not greater than zero so this is as
long as the trésor position Y is greater
than zero
else if it's not greater than zero
anymore which means we reach the center
of the screen like this as you can see
what we want to do now well this is
where the magic happens here we're gonna
check if the attack is not started so
attack started notice the exclamation
mark and I have talked about this
numerius of times in my tutorials the
exclamation mark makes what's after it
opposite so essentially when you see an
exclamation mark you will think of it
like this you're testing if something
did not happened because if you test it
like this you are testing if attack
started then do something but with an
exclamation mark you're testing if the
attack did not start think of it like
that why well because here we have just
declared attack started by default if I
don't write is equal to true the default
value of a boolean is false so if you
just declare a boolean like this this
attack right here has false for its
value so you don't need to type here is
equal to false you can do it but you
don't need to because the default value
is false now because of that if the
attack is not started this exclamation
mark if this is false exclamation mark
will make it the opposite what's
opposite of false true and vice-versa so
if the attack did not start we're gonna
see here attack started not attack speed
attack started is now equal to true so
that this if statement does not get
executed again so attack now is started
and I went to the bottom of the script
so now attack is started so attacks is
true because now when we get to this if
statement exclamation mark will make it
the opposite if the value is true
what's opposite of true/false you got
that right my brother so here since the
attack is started we're gonna call start
Karrueche because we're gonna create a
KO routine that is going to be called
attack player this is the name of the
core routine which we still did not
create so it's giving us a red warning
and what we want to do here well we want
to create an AI enumerator
like this and we're gonna name it attack
player so what we want to do inside of
this attack player function well we want
to yield return new waitforseconds so we
want to wait 4 seconds and we're gonna
wait 1.5 of a second when the b gets to
the middle of the screen so you know
that graph that I have well drawn for
some reason I don't have my highlight
tool here so when the middle of the
screen is here let's say our B is here
when that happens we will trigger this
right here and we will wait 1.5 seconds
and then we will start charging at the
player and in order to start charging at
the player what we need to do we need to
say here transform that rotation because
we just want to rotate our be a little
bit we're gonna make it equal to you
quaternion ealer
and here we're gonna say new vector3 and
we're gonna say 0 for the x 0 for the y
and for the Z we're gonna say random
range from 0 F to negative 45 F in
degrees and we need to close one more
parenthesis and bam we are done so this
is just gonna rotate our be a little bit
and let me show you what I mean so for
example if I take the player here and if
I rotate him on the z axis you see he's
gonna be rotated something like this
well we want to rotate the B for example
like this and make it charge and the
player just so that it looks like you
know when Falcons go down to chase the
bird or whatever that effect we want to
achieve so here we're also gonna say
move and attack is equal to true and we
want to invoke a function that is called
deactivate and we are gonna invoke it in
5 seconds
is this the activate function well this
is a functions if you're gonna create
here void deactivate which is simply
gonna call the game object set activity
false so first we're gonna attack we're
gonna allow the bee to attack after 1.5
seconds and when the bee attacks is
gonna go outside of the screen we're not
gonna see it anymore
it's not gonna be visible it's not gonna
go downwards we need to deactivate it
somehow because you know what I said
about those game objects when we don't
need them we can simply deactivate them
or otherwise they will take up memory in
our game but we don't have a use for
them because while we are not using them
and then we will invoke and invoke if I
hover over let me see if there is
explanation yes here it is invokes the
method method name in time seconds this
is the method name in a string so you
see quotes this is a string and this is
the method name which is this one right
here so this one right here method or
function this is that this right here it
will invoke it in five seconds so this
is like a timer before deactivate is
called now what about this move and
attack well this one is gonna be called
right here inside of the else statement
right outside of this if statement so or
actually excuse me not here but we are
gonna call it outside of the if-else
statement so let me just close this here
outside of the if-else statement because
well we don't need it to be inside of
the out statement right here we're gonna
say if move and attack so if we can move
and we can attack what we want to do if
so if we are not attacking right which
means we are attacking left we're gonna
call transform position and we're gonna
say minus equals to vector three dot
right and we're gonna multiply that with
the attack speed and multiply that with
time dot delta time Y vector three right
well because if you hover over it that
is writing shorthand for as you can see
here vector three one zero zero this
denotes the right side as I said
positive side on the x axis is to the
right negative is to the
so if we are attacking you see here we
are not attacking right actually so that
means that we need to subtract from our
while position using here right else you
see here else we're gonna say transform
that position plus equals to vector
three right multiplied with the attack
speed not attack right attack speed
multiply the time that Delta time as you
can see right here so if we are not
attacking to the right that means we are
attacking to the left side so we are
subtracting from our position why
subtracting let me go here again
dropping this this is the positive this
is the well this right here is the
negative this right here is the positive
and this is the x-axis if we are not
attacking to the right that means we are
attacking to the left which means we're
going to the negative this right here is
negative this is the negative which
means we need to subtract from our
position to go to the negative side else
if we are attacking right which is well
this one right here else we need to go
to the positive so here is positive like
this so we are going to deposit it which
means we need to add to our button this
is or actually to our position at your
button because as I already explained
the positive side is the right side so
let's test it out and see if it actually
works because we have everything
attached onto me if I hit the play
button let's wait for the B to be
spawned when we spawn the B and right
away we see the B now please pay
attention pay attention now when the B
comes down here it is notice now the B
is here notice now it's gonna start
attacking BAM you see the B wants to
attack the player let me see again if we
have another B come on where you are BBB
BBB BBB nope
we are spawning ninjas and flags and
again we are spawning flags and ninja
come on man spawn the B so that don't
need to go and put all B's here it is
one more B notice now please take a look
at pay attention when the B comes out
here it is notice it's gonna stop here
and bam it's gonna start attacking you
see did you see the B went to attack the
player because it reached the middle of
the screen so the else statement gets
invoked if we did not attack we're gonna
say attack started
start the co-routine which will wait 1.5
of a second it will rotate the beam and
it will allow it to move and attack what
happens when we are allowed to move an
attack we will test on which side we are
attacking if it's the left side we will
go to the left side I'm gonna go here
inside of our enemy prefabs here is our
ninja enemy we will need to remove and I
mean move script ik as well we don't
need it on the ninja anymore we're gonna
create his own script and going inside
of our scripts folder enemy scripts I'm
gonna right-click and create a new
folder which I'm gonna call ninja
scripts inside of the ninja scripts
right-click create a c-sharp script and
call it ninja script yes I know how
creative I am really creative so moving
back here prefabs enemy prefab ninja
enemy here he is attach that ninja
script on him double-click it and open
it right here in monodevelop
let me just find it here it is as always
I don't even have to tell you anymore
that I'm tagging the class with the
class tag giving a little bit of space
and we need a couple of variables so
what do we need well we need a public
float move speed which by default is 5
we also need a private float camera Y
which is the Y of the camera and a
private bull attacked player like this
now also what we need is a public game
object so public game object which I'm
going to call shuriken so what is this
shuriken well it's the thing that we are
gonna throw
at our player so we need to create it
which is or that is located right here
in our sprites enemies and obstacles and
here it is this is our shuriken we need
to set the sprite mode here to multiple
instead of single hit apply here at the
bottom open sprite editor and click
slice automatic slice unity will slice
it for us and bam we are good to go so
we have a slice here here here here here
and we have one more right here and one
more here so we have the animation for
our shuriken I'm gonna hit apply and bam
we are done so we need to now drag all
of these animations so from 0 up to 7
select all of these and drag and drop
them right here in our scene view we
need to go into the animations folder
new folder and I'm gonna call this
shuriken animations inside of this one
simply call this animation shuriken
so shariq an animation and I'm gonna hit
save and bam here we are of course it's
too large as you see here we're not
gonna throw this mega shuriken
Zillah on our ninja instead we are gonna
well resize it first i'm gonna rename it
here inside of our hierarchy panel to
shuriken set the scale point to point to
4 X and the y and we are gonna apply a
circle Collider so not a box Collider
but a circle Collider 2d which you see
this one right here
and we are gonna apply a rigidbody 2d
which is gonna be kinematic so here
we're gonna set it to be kinematic and
we are gonna tack our shuriken as the
enemy so here I'm gonna tag him as the
enemy tack now we do need to go here
inside of prefabs enemy prefabs and drag
and drop our shuriken because hey we
need it as a prefab so we can select the
ninja enemy now and here for the
shuriken game object drag and drop the
shuriken itself so here it is here is
our shuriken and we have
everything what we need to start coding
our ninja so what do we need in the
start function well in the start we need
to calculate camera Y which is going to
be equal to camera main
transform.position
dot Y minus 10 because while we are
gonna use this to calculate when we are
gonna deactivate our ninja below the
update function we're gonna create a
void move function so void move and here
we are going to simply say vector3 temp
is transform.position
temp dot y not equals but y minus equals
to the move speed multiply that with
time Delta time and transform position
is now equal back to temp this will move
them ninja down as we already did before
and we're going to call this function
inside of the update now this is nothing
new we did this already now below this
one we're gonna create void deactivate
which is also going to be called in the
update function so avoid the activate
like this open closed curly brackets
call it in the update function like this
and here we're simply going to test if
the transform position Y which is the
current Y position of the ninja enemy is
less than the cameras Y position we are
simply going to call our game object set
activity false and bam we are done now
inside of this one this move function we
are going to detect if our so if
transform dot position so that's
position that Y is less than 0 so if
it's less than 0 why am i testing if
it's less than 0 well we have already
explained our ninja is gonna be spawned
somewhere around here on top and the
middle of the screen is 0 so the middle
of the screen is 0 so as soon as our
ninja reaches the middle of the screen
when the ninja so when the ninja reaches
middle of the screen what we want to do
is the following we want to tell
if we did not attack the player so if we
are on the middle of the screen and we
did not attack the player if we are in
the middle of the screen and and we did
not attack the player what we want to do
we want to attack the player so here
we're gonna say attack player is true so
that this if statement right here does
not get executed again this right here
again will calculate or we will know
that we have reached the middle of the
screen when we are less than zero or
equal to zero we have reached the middle
of the screen with our ninja and if we
did not attack the player then we are
gonna attack the player so attack is
true and we're simply gonna call here
instantiate our shuriken game object at
our current position using quaternion
identity so this is simply gonna
instantiate the shuriken game object now
we can test it out right now but we will
have a funny effect will instantiate the
shuriken but it will stay there as you
will see now just in a moment let me
wait for the ninja so the B has been
spawn flagged now come on spawn the
ninja everytime when you need something
to be spawned it is not so here it is we
have the ninja enemy notice now Babb UC
ninja was spawned but hey he fired the
shuriken this one also fired the
shuriken but the shuriken stays at one
place and by the way if I go here in
assets prefabs enemy prefabs I'm gonna
select the shuriken go in to the
animator and here is the shuriken
animation I'm gonna set it to be twice
the speed so twice its own speed so that
while the animation goes faster what we
need to do now we need to go inside of
our scripts enemy scripts and then ninja
scripts we need to create a script for
the shuriken itself so here I'm simply
gonna say not JavaScript who uses
JavaScript anymore I mean just kidding
but anyways here we're gonna say
shuriken script this one is gonna be
attached on the shuriken itself so if I
go back here
so yeah get some errors here that are
not wanted I'm just see if I can run
yeah I will need to read restart my
unity so just a second if I go here in
prefabs enemy prefabs sure it can let me
just add component sure you can script
did I detach the shuriken scripts let me
just see what this is new behavior okay
come on let me go here in scripts and
any scripts ninja scripts okay do we
have this script not right now yeah you
see this weird error for reason I left
the video like this I don't know what
just happened and why did I gut this
error but anyways let me just go here
too sure you can game object here he is
so we have the shuriken add component
sure you can script and we are good to
go so if I run the game now let me just
see if we can run it yes we can
you saw that I have created that C sharp
or JavaScript file and I have deleted it
and afterwards we got that errors so
yeah unities full of bugs as any other
thing that you will find on the Internet
so this is how you fix that particular
team that's the reason why I did not cut
that out from the video anyways moving
forward here we have our shuriken script
so what we want to do with our shuriken
scripting well first we are gonna have
here private bull attack right this is
gonna determine how we are attacking
from the left side or from the right
side same thing as we did with our be
exact same thing right here we need to
know from which side is the shuriken
fired because the ninja can be on the
left or on the right so we need to know
which side are we and where we need to
go right below here we need a private
float private float attack speed which
is going to be equal to 6 f so this is
the speed of the attack in the awake
function action I'm gonna do that in the
start I am gonna use transform rotation
is gonna be equal to quaternion ealer
and here I'm gonna pass
vector 3 0 for the X 0 for the Y and for
disease it's gonna be random so random
that range from let's say 45 or negative
45 - 45 or we can test it out so you can
either choose negative 45 or 45 or 45
then negative 45 this is just you rotate
the shuriken itself same thing as we did
with the B so this is exactly the same
thing that we're doing with the B right
here just rotating it a little bit so
that it is it's like towards the player
so it's looking towards the player where
we are actually attacking we are also
below gonna calculate are we gonna
attack from the right or from the left
so we're gonna see here if our transform
position X is greater than 0 which means
that we are on the right side then we
are attacking to the left so here we're
gonna say attack right is gonna be equal
to false else here our attack right is
gonna be equal to true now what is this
here we have already explained if the
position X is greater than 0 that means
we are on the right side because 0 is in
the middle the positive side is on the
right the negative side is on the left
for the x axis for the Y positive is up
and negative is down so if we are
greater than 0 that means we are on the
positive side which is the right side so
we need to attack towards the left side
which is logic because if I go here just
so that someone but someone is confused
so this is 0 right here this is the
positive side on the X and if we are
here so this is our ninja right here he
throws the shuriken from here so this is
the shuriken which means that this right
here we are greater than our X is
greater than 0 we are in the positive
side so we need to go towards the left
side right here which means attack right
is false in this case otherwise if we
are on the left so if our ninja is here
you see if the ninja is here and he
throws the shuriken from here like this
we are going to this side which is the
positive side
so attack right will be equal to true
because while we are going to the right
side and also what we need to do is
invoke a function called deactivate
which we still did not create but we
will and we're gonna invoke it in five
seconds after we attack so what we are
gonna do below here we are simply gonna
create boy deactivate because if we
don't have the function with that name
BAM we will get an error and here is
simply gonna call game object set active
to false and bam we are done for
deactivating the game object of course
in the update we need to move our
shuriken in the right direction so if we
don't attack to the right so if we are
attacking to the left side so if not
notice that Commission mark which will
make what's after in the opposite if
attack right is false this will make it
true which means if we are not attacking
to the right meaning we are attacking to
the left so left
we are gonna say transform position
minus equals vector three right
multiplied with the attack speed
multiplied with time dot Delta time and
here in the else statement we are gonna
do the opposite so here we need to go to
the right side so here we're gonna say
right and here we are gonna say plus
equals because plus or positive is going
to the right side minus or negative is
going to the left side so I have
explained that again I don't care if you
are like okay you explained it two
thousand times I'm gonna explain it to a
thousand times anymore what did I just
say anyways I'm just kidding but we are
done with this we can go here and we can
now test it out so if I hit the Run
button let us just hope that the ninja
will be spawned very soon so we have the
B clone flag
come on waiting for that ninja we have
the tree we have the tree again tree
again here is our enemy ninja finally
notice now when the ninja comes here is
you see he threw that shuriken on us he
threw that shrieking come on one more
please one more one more one more where
is the ninja man when you need so here
we have one more ninja wait for it wait
for it BAM you see he threw chicken why
don't we get BAM he threw the shuriken
and also notice these shuriken x' they
are being deactivated so they are here
you see shuriken one is here let me see
the top one so the top one is here you
see where he is he has been deactivated
knows this one is right here if I can
run the game cmp deactivate yeah here he
is he just got deactivated same as the
BCB when they get at the same position
because I'm leaving the same number of
time for them you see here is the
shuriken here it is here it is here it
is and bam he is deactivated take the
animation panel and put him right here
and we're gonna select the player but
before that let me just go in sprites
and then play here and here we have the
falldown animations which are gonna be
the player dead animation so select the
player in the hierarchy and here create
a new clip and I'm gonna go in
animations and then player animation
here here it is and I'm gonna call this
one player died right so player has died
from the right side so we're gonna play
that animation and I am gonna put this
right here falling down this one right
here and this one I'm gonna put it right
here something like this let me just go
here inside of our animation or actually
move the animation panel and select the
player so now you see this is what we
want to achieve now in regards to the
position of the player I am gonna go on
frame 16 so something like this frame 60
and I'm gonna hit the recording button
set the player at Y or actually not y
equal to 0 Y will be 1 but X will be
equal to 0 something like this and I'm
gonna say Y well down like this
something like this and let me see this
animation uh so when we play the
animation
okay this is what we want so this is
what do you want simply player falling
down it's like when he gets hit he will
simply fall down and we'll play the
sound and so on and so forth so this is
what we want exactly if I go and put
this animation panel right here I will
need to create player diets from the
left side so create a new clip is going
to be player died left and I'm gonna hit
enter attached the same animation so
fall down fall down 0 1 and fall down 0
2 and let me just take the clip so
something like this go back here now
what is the catch with this animation
while the catch is that we are gonna set
the player to be at this side and this
is his scale right here we're gonna go
on frame 60 now and we are gonna send
the player well to fall down and let me
just move him down something like this
and voila
we're good to go this is for his left
animation because when he dies from the
left side he needs to fall from the left
side we don't want him to fall well he
dies from this side so when he is on the
left so he's here and we played the
player died right so player starts
falling down from the right side that's
why we have created these two animations
so something like this so what we need
to do now well we have the player when
we select him right here you see in the
animator he has player died right and
player died left as you can see here
died right died left here he is and now
we can go into some scripting so right
here on the top inside of our player
script which is this one right here
below our private ball jump we need a
couple of more variables so we need a
serialized field which is going to be
our audio source which is going to be
audio kill to play the kill animation
and audio jump and we also need a
serialize field
this is gonna be private audio clip
which I'm gonna call dead sound and we
also need a private bull is alive which
by default is equal
to true this is a lie will determine if
the player is alive or not
before we start attaching these
components in regards to is alive you're
gonna take all of the code in the update
function and we're gonna test if is
alive so if the player is actually alive
then we are gonna well call all of the
code right here and also in the jump
function right here if the player is
alive so is alive come on is alive so if
the player is alive then we will be able
to jump in here if not is so excuse me
for this one if the player is alive then
we'll be able to jump if the player has
died then no jumpy jumpy for the player
and let us attach these components now
so we have these audio sources and the
audio clip if we go here select our
player we will need to attach few audio
sources so audio source one and let me
just move the script down
yes break the prefab I don't care
because we will reconnect it again add
another audio source and move the
component down so uncheck play on awake
for both of these and we will for the
first one so here we have audio source
we are gonna attach this sward slash and
for the second audio we're gonna attach
jump new and we will drag and drop them
so the sward slash is gonna go right
here audio kill this is the smart slash
and jump is gonna be under jump so come
on why is it not giving me come on
why aren't you scrolling down okay so
audio jump is gonna be here and for the
dead sound you're gonna play hurt too so
attach these like this and then hit
apply so that these changes apply to the
pray prayer player player player ok
player player testing I can now say
player to the player prefab so again the
Swart slash audio source will go under
audio kill and jump new audio source
will go under audio jump and for the
death sound we are gonna play
hurt too we will also go here and when
we jump so after we say jump is equal to
true we're gonna call audio jump and
we're gonna say play since we play the
jump sound we're gonna do the same exact
thing right here in the jump function
and that will be that in regards to you
well what we did so far what we need to
do now is that we need to create your
void ontriggerenter 2d to detect
collision between the player and other
game objects and collision 2d takes or
ontriggerenter takes a collider which
I'm gonna call target not try it but
target like this and now we are gonna
test some things right here if we
collide with some game objects if we
have jumped so if we have jumped we are
in the air we are untouchable we can
kill the player we can actually kill the
ninja enemy ninja we can kill his
shuriken we can kill the bee we can kill
everything that we touch while we jump
but if we don't jump if we are not
jumped like this then we will die but if
we have jumped and if the target dot tag
is equal to the enemy but we have jumped
we are in the air we can kill our
enemies so we can say target that game
object that said active is false and we
are gonna play audio kill so how do you
kill that play to play the audio kill
sound this is if we have jumped because
when we are in the air ninja is you know
doing that backflip or the flip rotating
and then he throws his knife and kills
everybody so yeah that's the point of
the game so when the ninja is in the air
while he has jumped we can kill any
enemy but else if we did not jump and
our target attack is equal to the enemy
so if we are not we did not jump and the
enemy touches us we're gonna call a
function called player died which we
still did not create so we're gonna
create it right here so void player died
like this just so that we have the
function for the reference and right
here below if our target dot tag is
going to be equal to the enemy
we are also dead and we are gonna call
player died function so that we will die
of course and we will never come back
and you can come back from the dead to
haunt me anyways this is the point of
the game in the player died function
we're gonna call here audio kills audio
kill that clip is gonna be equal to our
death sound and we're gonna call play
this will change to the dead sound of
the players so clip is the actual clip
this one right here that we have
attached let me just go here come on
sometimes it does not allow me to scroll
so you see that audio clip that is
attached in the audio source we have
sword slash for this one and for this
one we have jump new now we also have
this hurt or our dead sound so when the
player dies we will play that dead sound
and in order for us to play that that's
I mean we need to change the clip to our
dead sound and then we are gonna play it
is alive is now false which means that
we're not be able to jump so we'll be
false this right here will not be
executed and this right here will also
not be executed because well we have
died and well yeah we cannot jump when
we are dead
if the transform that position that X is
greater than 0 we have died from the
right side so we need to fall from the
right side so we're gonna see here nm
play the player died right animation
like this else we have died from the
left side so here we're gonna say player
died left and voila we are good to go
here we're gonna call our game play
controller so game play controller to
call his instance to say the game is
over to share the game over tab but we
are still not done with that and we will
simply say time that time skill is 0 to
stop our game so what did we do well
created those two animations in this
video which we already saw so created
those two animations player dead or
player died from the right and player
died from the left side and here in our
ontriggerenter if we have jumped which
we will determine you see when
jump so here jump we will see jump is
true while that is true and we touch one
of the enemies we will kill the enemy
because we have jumped we will kill the
enemy else you see here if else else if
we did not jump and we touch the enemy
then we will die also when we touch the
tree no matter if we have jumped or not
we will die so let's test that out and
if I go here console clear let me just
lower the volume a little bit because
you're gonna hear some sounds notice not
when we jump we hear the sound and
notice now when any enemy comes here we
can kill for example this squirrel can
we kill the squirrel no we cannot
because we did not tag the squirrel so
in prefabs and any prefabs flag squirrel
is not tagged with the enemy tagged yeah
it's a good idea to tag them so bee is
tagged with enemy flag don't tag the
flag flag is not important
squirrel will be tagged with the enemy
ninja enemy is the enemy shuriken is
also and tree will be tagged as the
enemy tree so now we can test it out so
notice now when we jump and we touch the
squirrel or the ninja only the tree can
kill us if we jump so the tree we're not
gonna touch we need to avoid the tree
you see I have jumped and killed the
ninja so I have jumped and killed the
ninja we heard the sound you see now
when the bee comes close to me notice
now damn I have killed it I have to kill
the squirrel also so let's die and see
if it's actually working so yeah we have
died now what is the problem here as you
can see you see the animation well the
problem is that we need to select the
player since we set here timescale tb0
when the time scale is zero
physics calculation will not work
animations will not work as you just saw
but we can fix the thing with the
animation and in order to do so select
the player and in his animator component
you see the animator right here you see
the update mode is set to normal so we
have the update mode to dropdownlist set
it to on scaled time this means it will
not be affected by timescale even if the
time scale is zero the animation will
still play till the end and let's test
it out actually and see if
actually works I'm saying actually too
many times but let's hope that this
squirrel will kill me so the squirrel
did not give me yeah but you see the
tree have has killed me but you see the
problem you see what's the problem well
the problem is that our animation is
looping so go in to the animator panel
select the player died right
double-click it uncheck the loop time
player died left also double-click it
uncheck the loop time so for both of
these animations simply double-click
them loop time will be checked you need
to uncheck it click them loop time will
be checked on check the loop time let's
test them one more time and hoping that
everything is ok so now we have the
player here we have the ninja enemies so
let's hope that the ninja enemy again
and Jeremy's here and I've just avoided
these obstacles and bam you see I have
died and I have fallen down and the game
has stopped the animation is not playing
anymore so on and so forth but we see
that everything is working for death
we're gonna right click on the canvas
and we're gonna create a UI panel so
we're gonna create a panel that we are
gonna name score panel or score
background which is gonna have source
image score background so here it is
this is the score background image let
me just select here in the image
property the color and I'm gonna set the
Alpha to full so 255 because I want it
to be visible and not transparent
let me change here so if I go here and
set it in the middle so this is for the
anchor set it at the middle and I'm
gonna change the width to 225 change the
height to let's say 144 this is gonna be
our score panel right here that you see
I'm also gonna right-click and create a
UI text below it and for the text this
is where we are actually gonna display
our score text and we're gonna call it
score text and I'm gonna set the width
of the score text you
well 225 hike is gonna be 144 and I'm
gonna set the alignment at the middle
center I'm gonna change the color of the
text to white you see all of these
properties are in the inspector panel
when you select the text itself set the
font size to 48 actually could be 50 so
50 for the font size and the beginning
score will be 1 let me just take a look
at it somewhere around here I will need
to put it a little bit down so if I
select this corner I just zoom in here I
need to put it something like this yeah
so that it will be in the middle so
where is my score here it is I cannot
see it because of the camera so I'll
move it upwards here it is something
like this for our scores so this is what
we want let me just move the score a
little bit further down let's say
negative 30 on the Y and then we are
done now what we want to do is animate
the score background coming in so for
that we are gonna set the score back or
on X 650 initial height you see here
initial height or where it is and inside
of our animations I'm gonna create a new
folder for the score background
animation capitalize a animation like
this so I will need to go into the
animator
select the score background hit create
and save it in score background
animation so here score BG Adam hit
enter
go on frame 60 right here hit the
recording button and I'm gonna put it
down at 310 for the y-axis so this is
his animation this right here so when we
start our game we will see it animating
and we will see it animating again and
again and again because it loops so we
need to go in to the animator himself
here he is
double click it uncheck the loop time
and let me check it again and I'm gonna
see the speed the initial speed is gonna
be 0.5 so notice here when we run our
game
the score is slowly gonna start to calm
down as we just saw the problem is that
the score is not moving at all
we have died by the way so the score is
not moving at all or actually changing
so how can we change the score well for
that always there is a script to the
rescue so new folder' game manager
scripts here inside of our game manager
folder I am gonna create a new C sharp
scripts I'm gonna call game play
controller who is gonna control our
gameplay I will create an empty game
object here let me put it 0 0 0 for x
y&z this does not matter at all I just
like it like that so game play
controller and attach it on the game
play controller game object so now we
can start to code our final well lines
of code and here tag the class as always
hold enter to give a little bit of space
so what do we need
well we need a public static game play
controller instance which we are gonna
call here to create that instance so
here we're gonna say void make instance
and here we're gonna test if our
instance is equal to null that means
that we need to set the instance to be
equal to this so here I'm gonna say
instance is equal to this and this is
gonna be called in the awake function so
make instance I've talked about this
numerius of times what is this doing how
can we control sing or create
Singleton's so on and so forth so you
can watch other videos for that I'm not
gonna react splain myself here we need a
public text but in order to use it he is
located under unity engine that you I as
you can see here so we need to type
above here using unity engine dot you I
which now allows us to type private text
and I'm gonna call it score text so
score text like this we also need a
private integer for score this is well
the integer that's gonna count our score
and voila that is that so what do we
need to do now is that we need to well
calculate the score and we are gonna do
that in a function that is called count
score which is going to be ienumerator
so ienumerator which is a KO routine
count score so count score like this we
are gonna do the following yield return
new waitforseconds and we're gonna wait
0.1 seconds so one tenth or yeah one
tenth of a second and then we're gonna
call score plus plus to increment the
score incrementing the score and now
we're gonna call score text dot X is
gonna be equal to you score to string
because we need to convert this integer
score to string because while our text
only accepts strings and we need to call
here start co-routine count scores it we
start counting our score and don't
forget the parentheses here now we need
to when we start our game so here in our
void start function we need to get a
reference to the score text itself so we
need to see here score text is gonna be
equal to game object find the game
object with the name score text now this
right here the score text need to make
needs to match up with this name right
here so here it is make sure that these
names are the same so find the game
object with the name score text and get
the component text from it and voila
simple as that and afterwards simply
start the kill routine to count our
score so this is the KO routine that
we'll start counting our score and well
when we run our game the KO routine will
start to count the score which we can
test right now if we go here in unity
hit the play button just wait for unity
to load notice now it is counting the
score but why what what what let me just
go here set it that's right now so if I
hit the play button
yeah now everything is okay just set the
score text well position Y at 0 so 0 for
the X 0 for the Y and you see now it is
counting the score but when we die you
see here when we die what we want to do
we want to call here as you already saw
we're on a call here our gameplay
controller instance that the game is
over but before the game is over we need
to create the game over panel which is
gonna well be the game over panel so
here I am gonna go back in unity editor
I'm gonna create a new panel so you i
panel here he is set the background as
the score background again set the Alpha
at 255 set the anchor in the middle so
the width of this one is gonna be 385
the height is gonna be 297 and this is
gonna be our end and also and panel and
for our end panel we also need to add UI
text now this text is gonna display the
final score so I'm gonna name it final
score and the width of our final score
is gonna be 270 the height is gonna be
99 I'm gonna set his Y position at 50 I
am gonna change his font size to 40 not
50 but 40 I'm gonna see here 1 which is
not important and I'm also gonna set the
alignment at the middle so going from
the left side so left middle and I'm
also gonna change the color so here I'm
gonna change the color and voila we are
good to go let me just take it take this
dude so here middle I think everything
is okay yeah everything should be okay
yeah this is it so here I'm gonna say
height which is our final score let's
say 1000 and below these two we are
gonna attach our buttons so I'm gonna go
here create a UI
button so one button we have here which
I'm gonna remove the text from this is
gonna be our again button which will
prompt us to play the game again so play
the game again 145 for the width and the
height I'm gonna say 64 and I am gonna
position this one at negative 75 for the
X and the y is gonna be negative 32 and
here let me just go inside of my sprites
backgrounds and buttons here it is our
again button let me just select it and
drag and drop it right here and bam this
is our again button I'm gonna duplicate
this one so this again is duplicated I'm
gonna call the new one menu and let me
just find our menu it's somewhere around
here so here it is now the menu I will
need to go into our sprite editor and
slice it slightly do I need to slice it
here actually revert let me just go here
and set it to be multiple apply sprite
editor and I'm gonna slice it like this
just so because the image is distorted a
little bit you see the image is not that
good but if the image is good you don't
need to do this anyways for our menu
here I am gonna attach the menu what am
I doing here so yeah here it is
menu let me attach it right here and
back here we have our menu now the menu
is again gonna be at negative or
actually positive 75 am I gonna leave it
like this actually yes I will leave it
like this I don't care I just don't care
anyways I'm just kidding but this is
what we want now I am also gonna
creative animation for our panel so our
end panel is going to be at 704 the
height initially so 704 the height
initially go here into the animation
create a new animation in animations I'm
gonna create a new folder and panel
animation hit create and here I'm gonna
see and panel animation and voila here
we are now where am I gonna put this end
panel so let's go on frame 6
first frame 60 hit the recording button
y-position 77 and this is it so this is
for our panel you see Babb and it is
going here now if we are smart which we
are we're gonna learn from our mistakes
so we forgot to uncheck the loop for the
score background we are not gonna forget
that for the end panels so uncheck the
loop time I'm also gonna right-click and
create an empty state here and I'm gonna
call this one idle and I'm gonna set so
right-click on the idle and click this
set as default layer' state because we
don't want to play the ant panel
animation until we need to do so and
this end panel I'm gonna call it here
ant panel so this is how I'm gonna call
the enemy should make sure that you
don't forget this because we will need
to call the animator of the end panel so
ant panel here it is to play that
animation we don't want to play it right
away because well it makes no sense to
play the animation right away so right
click create an empty state which is
this one name in idle right click on the
state and click set as layer default
state if I go back in my script here I
need a couple of more game objects so I
need a public game object which I'm
gonna call score panel and I need a
public text which is gonna be our end
score and a public animator and panel
Adam I need all of this and we need to
drag and drop them so go back in our
unity select the game play controller
for the score panel select the score
background for the final or end score
select the final score right here and
for the end panel and I'm select the end
panel right here so what we need to do
now well we simply need to create a
public function so public void game over
what do we want to do here well simply
we're gonna call our score panel set act
if T Falls to deactivate our score panel
which is well this the one that is
counting the score
this one when we run the game so this
panel right here we want to deactivate
it we don't want it to be there when the
player dies and then we're gonna call
our end score and we're going to say dot
text is going to be equal to height like
this plus our score to display the final
score and finally end panel Adam dot
play not playback time but play the
animation with the name and panel and we
are calling this right here as you can
see so we're calling this right here and
simply uncomment this line of code now
out let's test it out and see if it
actually works so when I hit the play
button let us just wait for us to die so
here we have our panel here we have our
B we have the ninja enemy let's hope
that somebody will kill us from it okay
then we have died let's wait for the end
score panel it's not appearing because
we are or I am you are not you're smart
I'm stupid because I forgot to select
the end panel set the update mode to
unskilled time because we are setting
time that scale or time scale you see
here to 0 so we need unskilled time for
the animator let's try this again so
let's wait for us to die here we have
the flag we have the B come on let's sum
let us somebody kill us where is the
tree here it is and then we have died
you see height is here now we have our
problem here we have the animations
playing too fast so I'm gonna say here
0.5 so point 5 for the animation we see
that the animation is there I set point
5 which will make the animation go
slower
now before we proceed to test that out
again we have two buttons and I'm gonna
create functions that we're gonna add to
those buttons so we are gonna have
public void again to restart the game
but before we restart the game it's a
good time to set it's a good time it's a
good idea to test to set the time scale
back to 1 and we're gonna call the scene
manager so right here on the top type
using Unity engine scene management
which is going to allow us to use our
scenes and move from one scene to
another this is how we actually load
levels so here we're gonna call the
scene manager that load scene and I'm
gonna call here again scene manager that
get active scene that name which is
gonna reload the same scene and here
we're gonna have a public avoid menu
which is gonna bring us back to the main
menu and simply here we're gonna see the
same thing time that time skill is one
and scene manager that not seen but
scene manager that load scene we are
gonna load the main menu scene so before
we proceed to test it out again we will
need to go here and select again and the
menu button so again in menu button
click the plus button right here on them
drag and drop the gameplay controller
here and for the again I'm gonna select
again for the menu I am gonna select the
menu not not game over but man you come
on here where is the menu I've talked
about this to marys of times this is how
we can attach a game object to a button
and make it execute a function from one
of the scripts attached on that game
object in our case we have again and we
have the menu so as you can see here on
the again we drag and drop our gameplay
controller here then from the drop-down
list we select the functions that are
attached on that game object so we have
the game play controller and we have
here a list of functions we have our
function called again we select it which
means when we press the again button BAM
this again right here function will be
executed now we will have one problem
that we will solve in a moment but let
us wait for our player to die let's hope
so we have the B we have the ninja enemy
command come on where is some of these
ok BAM we have died you see here is our
height if we press again BAM we reload
the same well we reload the same scene
if we go back here or actually let me
just wait for it to die if I try to load
the main menu yeah may
I cannot load it and we see we have a
problem what is the problem here
well the problem is that we did not add
it to the build what is the build well
let me go here singh's main menu and go
under file build settings and here we
need to click Add open scenes this will
add the current scene to the build where
you are so we have the main menu now go
into the gameplay and also click Add
open seams and now we will be able to
load one scene and go from one scene to
another so if you don't do this we will
not be able to go as you just saw we
clicked on the manual it did not bring
us there because we did not add that
scene to you the manual I've talked
about this also in my previous tutorials
and I talked about this in my courses
now for the main menu here we also need
to attach a script so that we can click
this play button so in the scripts I'm
simply gonna right click here c-sharp
script main menu script and we can
create an empty game object so here I
can create an empty main menu controller
like this attach the main manuscript on
the main menu controller come on man
attach it double-click it we don't need
to give a little bit of space because
here we're only gonna have a public void
and here I'm gonna say play game and we
do need to type using Unity engine scene
management because we are gonna call
here scene manager dot C manager load
scene game play like this so we need to
go back in unity select our play button
so play BT and click the plus button
here attach the main menu controller and
then go here and select the play game
which will allow us to play our game
from the start so if we hit the play
button we have a nice main menu
everything is animating we click on play
we go here and start playing our game
let me just lower the volume a bit jumpy
jumpy jumpy jumpy ninja I will name this
game probably jumping in just so we have
here kill the squirrel kill the ninja
and his sure it can't kill the squirrel
again
kill the squirrel again and died and bam
we have reached the height of 50 or 152